make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
oh my god Rob core Doomsday Clock oh my
god this story is so good is this issue
this first issue is everything I hoped
it would be is an incredible start to an
incredible story I can I get mad I can
guaran-damn-tee that alright so a little
bit of history here the original
Watchmen comic in a lot of ways played
out like the film I mean there are a lot
of aspects of the film that were pretty
much the same there were two main
differences between the film and really
just one main difference between the
film and the comics the biggest
difference was that instead of
Ozymandias that any bombs in these
different cities across the world
instead what he did is he unleashed this
giant monster on the city of New York
but the whole idea remains the same the
world for the most part was on the brink
of chaos that nuclear war was going to
engulf everything it was like if the
cold war between the United States and
Russia never ended and so because of
that with the original Watchmen taking
place in 1985 the idea of Ozymandias was
if people cannot unite on their own then
what they need is they need a common
enemy a common goal they need a singular
banner to unite under and so creating
this this massive catastrophe in the
city of New York this massive event that
cost somewhere near the the lives of
three million people ultimately United
society in a way that people never
really thought before and so what we
find out in this story is that where the
end of the watchmen saw this unification
of humanities a sort of you know 1:1
pact one world kind of thing ultimately
by 1992 where this story kicks off it
had all gone to pot and the reason for
that was because in the original
watchmen comic horshack was basically
going through and he was notating
everything that had happened that was
the basis of war shacks journal it was
documenting this whole event that was
unfolding so by the time the story came
to an end and you found out that Adrian
Veidt this guy who was formerly a
superhero who had turned you know
philanthropist and businessman where he
was the one that was originally behind
it all this was basically documented at
were shacks journal so at the end of the
story when were shacks Journal was sent
to the press and the press began running
this article of the fact that it was all
just a giant ruse that it was what
people now refer to as the great lie the
society felt deeper into chaos than it
was before because now they felt like
they'd been tricked and they felt like
three million people had been sacrificed
as opposed to you know people finding a
hope on their own now this is cool geoff
johns is not really a writer to focus on
like the dark side of humanity but the
cool thing about this is that it almost
seems to hit it home as the nature of
people to take kind of a cynical
approach here and I'm not really cynical
by nature but the humanity was at a fork
in the road they were giving us
information that said hey look it was
basically a ruse it was this guy Adrian
Veidt the world's smartest man who had
engineered the deaths of three million
people to unite all of you under a
single banner because you were acting
like children and you couldn't do it on
your own and when humanity was given the
choice of will do we continue this trend
and do we say yeah I mean maybe he was
right maybe we did need a singular cause
and those three million people's
sacrifice can be honored by creating a
better world or we can just descend back
in the chaos again and just totally ruin
any sacrifice they made humanity chose
to descend back into chaos again and so
it's very much a kind of Grant Morrison
esque Alan Moore method of storytelling
where it's like where they they take
these kind of concepts and they
basically said all the worst things that
happen in the world happen because of
people because people do them maybe a
lot easier if we could point our finger
at a super villain but to quote you know
V for Vendetta if people are looking for
the guilty party they need only look
into a mirror and that's the whole point
of this that's the whole basis behind
this is to say humans are responsible
for all the terrible things that happen
and so one thing I want you guys to also
notice too is that we're getting this
sort of monologue this almost like a
diary entry in terms of how all this is
happening which is interesting because
war Shack died at the end of the first
Watchmen and so it's kind of cool
because the question becomes well who is
it that's narrating this who it is who
is it this going through and making this
whole discussion and talking about these
things now the other half of this is
that we end up finding out that after
the events of you know really like this
this revelation from Adrian Veidt so on
and so forth that political parties in
the United States began using it as a
means to try to consolidate you know
power under one another and that's kind
of the cool thing because in a lot of
ways this almost heaters on the basis
behind the the TV show Jericho oh how
many of the eyes ever saw Jericho but
Jericho was a great show it was
basically this show that took place from
the perspective of the people who lived
in a town called Yuriko and there's this
nuclear explosion in Colorado Springs I
think it was where NORAD is based but
people were just kind of freaking out
they were kind of panicking but what you
end up finding out is that that was not
the only nuclear detonation instead some
crazy faction got a hold of nuclear
weapons and detonated nuclear bombs in
26 major US cities basically bringing
America to its knees and then after that
you had the eastern United States which
is what was left of the federal gun
and then everything west of the
Mississippi or the Rocky Mountains I
came from Burt which was the Allied
States of America so you effectively had
the works being laid for a second Civil
War within the United States and all
that hindered on the last remaining
nuclear bomb and it was just a great
race to try to get it this is very much
the same way people consolidating power
is designed to illustrate absolute chaos
and complete and total pandemonium not
only that because of the fact that this
is all predicated on the great lie it
means not only is the United States
descending into madness it's also other
countries to all these different news
agencies are reporting about how Russia
is invading other territories expanding
its empire different things like that
and that's why it's kind of crazy
because we don't know which of these is
true and when I say which of these we'll
find out here in a second but we into
finding out from this whole you know a
bit of a monologue is that the news
network started publishing it the news
networks started talking about it then
the government started systematically
shutting them down the government just
has a sweeping amount of power more so
than it had before the president's kind
of out of the picture nobody really
cares about what it is that he's doing
they're trying to figure out what it is
is going on but Adrian Veidt is the
world's most wanted man the world's on
the hunt for Adrian Veidt as the what we
end up doing is we actually end up
having a member of the press who's
actually inciting rebellion among the
people rise up against your government
and they're immediately quashed there
immediately silence and the whole idea
is that in turn we basically get the
national news network this giant
propaganda piece and that shows you how
far things have fallen in the span of
seven years from the end of the first
Watchmen story until this one starts
humanity experienced this golden era of
peace and then humanity brought this
golden era of peace to an end and now we
basically have this propaganda machine
cranking out information Russia's
invaded Poland we have to respond with
nuclear weapons and so what we end up
doing is that in the middle of all this
panic in the middle of all this chaos
they basically pick up in a prison where
you know a guy's basically trying to
orchestrate a prison break by attacking
a guard and when he goes to knock this
guy out we end up having somebody pick
up the keys and this person is Rorschach
what how did horshack live where were
shot come from now here's the funny
thing
so we were at New York Comic Con and we
got the ashcan for this whole thing and
froze you guys you don't know the
ashcans basically like hey here's just
kind of a preview rough draft kind of a
thing on what the story's going to be
you know what the story's gonna look
like and it was super cool because like
myself in comic story
were sitting in the panel with like
Geoff Johns and maybe like five or six
hundred other people and Geoff Johns is
like hey so do you guys want to see like
the preview for like for Tuesday o'clock
and we're like yeah man like we really
want to see that and so he so he starts
running over like showing the previous
everything and he got to this point dude
the top plumb came off that place you
guys should have seen it it was bananas
people were freaking out over the fact
that were Shaq came back we basically
picked up with were Shaq as he makes his
way through and this is very Rorschach
asked in terms of how this thing unfolds
he went to a diner you know on you know
to get some breakfast and the woman that
normally serves this pancake syrup you
know her boyfriend took her you know out
back and then she came back with bruises
and a busted lip Rorschach found the guy
stabbed a fork through his tongue broke
his hands I mean it was it was amazing
it was it's just it's awesome to see
this this this cool monologue unfold but
were shocked is basically talking about
how the US gave Russia a four-hour
ultimatum if Russia does not back off
from invading Poland in four hours then
the United States is going to use
nuclear weapons now the whole idea
grabbing that idea of like the national
news network and the propaganda machine
and rolling it over into what were Shack
is basically telling us this is
basically nonsense is this scenario
where the United States government is
feeding the American people false
information under the auspices of
creating a reason for why it is that
they want to either attack Russia or
disable Russia or something along those
lines now the indication here is that
with Adrian Veidt having this global
sharing information for the most part
that Russia knows all the strategic
points of the United States and how to
basically [ __ ] the u.s. using nuclear
weapons and so the goal of the u.s. is
to create a common threat to say see
Russia's the bad guy stop protesting us
we need to worry about Russia everybody
focus on Russia and then launch nuclear
weapons in Russia what we end up finding
out is that where these nuclear weapons
are being prepared to launch you know
we're just they're just waiting on the
three-and-a-half hour mark to hit we end
up having Rorschach locate someone by
the name of marionette now there is a
reason for why these characters are here
and we'll talk about that in a second
but one thing I hope you also notice
about how Rorschach talks is that it's
very much in broken English when
horshack spoke in the Watchmen comics
for the most part it was kind of broken
to a degree but it was still like
traditional English you know regular
English the way that we normally speak
it does feed him to the idea that if
this is Rorschach who's returned for the
dead and things just
quite right from him you know right with
his character it was kind of cool in
terms of how this unfolds but with
regards to the character of marionette
were shocked popping up basically says
hey look I'm gonna hire you for a job
and the payment for this job is a
location of where your child is and this
is cool because marionette freaks out it
immediately tries to attack horshack now
from there her her idea is well did we
have to find my husband we have to find
mine and this is cool because once they
locate mine is in the middle of this
massive Prison Break regards are being
beaten up in different things like that
and we end up finding out that mine was
putting on somewhat of a show in the
sense that we're a couple of prisoners
consider him to be sort of nonsense the
fact that he never talks you know when
were shocked at marionette show up
marionette makes the case well this is
just part of my own show just wait and
watch and Mon basically responds by just
killing all these prisoners but the
reason why I say these are characters
but John's put in here intentionally was
because during New York comic-con John's
had basically said these are versions of
Punch and Julie now punch and Julie are
old Charlton comic characters and they
made their appearance back in Captain
Atom number 85 in 1967 now of course we
talked about Charlton comics before one
of a myriad of coming up with publishers
really from like the 1940s going into
the 1960s the problem was by the time
the 1970s and 80s came around
Charlton just wasn't able to stay afloat
anymore and so DC had basically
purchased up a lot of the characters
that they had and then wrote those
characters into DC itself which is where
we got Blue Beetle different things like
that but punch of Julie were basically
just these nonsensical characters they
were characters where they basically
found some alien technology they ran a
puppet show called Punch and Judy and
the whole thing was that when they
became criminals they started calling
themselves Punch and Julie and that was
really it most recently in DC rebirth
they were part of I am vein where Batman
broke into a Santa Prisca
where he was forming a suicide squad of
his own of sorts in order to invade
Bane's prison that was really the basis
behind that you know for the purpose of
taking psycho-pirate bring you back to
Gotham in order to cure Gotham girl
again I have that in the Batman playlist
you guys are welcome to check out that's
the actual punch and Julie over there
these characters mime and marionette are
based on those characters grabbing a
vehicle and taking off what they end up
doing is of course were shocked he's
making allusions to is to his partner
you know now the indication here is
because the direction they go in their
partner is actually Night Out and that's
cool here because they go to like you
know the the howl ship and they're in
the base of the old Nienow they have the
nine that will suit everything there but
what
finding out is his partner is not
neidell his partner is Ozymandias and i
was just like what no way it's crazy
because Ozymandias has been hiding
underground this entire time he's been
just underground and he basically
grabbed were shocked but we also find
out is this is not the Rorschach that we
know it's not the were shocked that
we're familiar with somebody took over
his name somebody took the title of were
shocked after the original Rorschach
died who that person is we don't know
but the cool thing about this is that
Ozymandias really kind of hits on the
mistake that he made what he says is I
do not have the means to fix the world
we don't even know if the world can be
fixed but if the world can be fixed if
it can be restored back to the place
that is supposed to be there's only one
person who can do it and that person is
dr. Manhattan we have to find dr.
Manhattan at this point we cut away from
the whole Watchmen from from everything
with the Watchmen and we pick up with
Superman what this does is it seems to
pick up with like a flashback or a dream
of sorts and he's actually talking to
Martha Kent talking to Jonathan Cain
about a problem that he's going to that
kind of a thing but notice the way this
is done this is throwback to Superman's
secret origin those guys don't know
Geoff Johns wrote a few secret origins
stories and for the most part secret
origins are just a line of publications
that DC has they're basically just more
condensed down versions of the origins
as they appear and they usually put like
two or three and any one particular
publication but the whole idea was that
with Geoff Johns secret origin of
Superman it was like a six or seven
issues story but detailed this brand new
origin for the character of Superman and
that's what's been used really as part
of DC rebirth in a lot of ways now
Superman reborn changed a lot of that
stuff but it also brought a lot of those
things back to so it kind of rolled in
this perfect origin for the new 52 flash
classic Superman melded into a singular
character but with regards to this
version of Superman we're kind of left
to assume that you know it's it's them
the one that we see now in DC rebirth
but it's not and we'll find out why here
in a second but the cool thing is that
he's basically reflecting on this whole
they owe this dance you know this dance
party of sorts that he's going to and
the funny thing is that back in in his
younger years Superman really kind of
had the hots for Lana Lang
she was the first person who learned
that he had powers basically and she was
the one that helped to train him to use
his powers to figure out how he could
fly to figure out how to control
vision different things like that and so
she was very much an intricate part of
him becoming a superhero as much as John
and Martha Kent were and teaching him
his moral compass but it's kind of cool
because back in these younger days where
he had feelings for Lana in a lot of
ways Pete Ross one of the other friends
of Clark Kent had was the first one to
ask out Longway the problem with this is
that is John and Martha Kent are driving
home they basically end up in a car
wreck and that's where they die and
Superman snaps out of it now the reason
why I say this is not the Superman that
we're familiar with is because
Superman's parents as far as I'm aware
never died in a car crash Jonathan and
Martha Kent have died but like usually
Jonathan died of a heart attack and
Martha Kent wasn't long after that their
passing has been done in different ways
but it's still kind of a big moment
because this seems to hit at the idea
this is not the Superman we're familiar
with this is a totally isolated Superman
if the events of you know Doomsday Clock
are taking place on a earth somewhere
then that means it's got to be taking
place on an earth in a different
universe and it was taking place in a
different universe and the washer rolled
into the DC universe or DC Multiverse
now then it stands to reason that
universe may very well have his own
version of Superman well the question
has to be asked if that version of Earth
has its own Superman where's he been all
this time and that's a crazy thing is
because again as far as I'm aware
Superman's parents never died in a car
crash now this may be a change and there
may be some part of his origin that I'm
missing over here and if there is I'm
sure a lot of you guys will will correct
me down in the comments but it's huge
this is big because what this does is a
deal it basically hints at this idea
Superman has never had a nightmare
before he's never experienced a bad
dream in his life you know him having
this nightmare means one of two things
it means either it's organic or
someone's messing with Superman but it's
kind of crazy because the question
becomes what happens next okay
so we are picking up with Doomsday Clock
part two and really in order to keep
from like spoiling the events of the
Watchmen because I know that while the
story is like 50 years old or 40 years
old or something crazy like that a lot
of people never read it I mean they saw
the movie but they never actually read
the comic so in order to keep from
spoiling the end of the comic we're not
going to go too deep into what the
aftermath of the comic is or at least
what happens at the end of the comic
what we will say is that with regards to
where Doomsday Clock picked up it
basically picked up with the end of the
world the fact that everything had come
crumbling down
and so really this deals with like these
these last vestiges these last moments
but for reasons that were never really
explained to us Ozymandias had gone as
far as to basically recruit the
characters of marionette and mime
I remember marionette in my and were in
a lot of ways the not really Joker
characters the characters were kind of
like comma just two jokers now in truth
the way there's the way they're kind of
being depicted here it's almost like
they're more of a joker Harley Quinn
relationship in the sense that I would
say Joker would be more like a
marionette and Harley Quinn might be
more like mine but we didn't really know
why awesome Andy has wanted in so much
we don't know why he brought them in
well what we end up doing is get this
kind of tape of course Ozymandias
basically gives them back the things
they normally neither their outfits
perfume for for marionette different
things like that but we end up you know
having this tape that's shown to
Rorschach and what this tape reveals is
that somewhere along the line over the
course of the careers of marionette in
Mon they had gone to rob a bank now of
course this bank robbery really kind of
played out the way we would expect it to
you in the sense that things went nuts
pretty fast
but along the way they're basically
greeted by the arrival of dr. Manhattan
now the crazy thing about this is that
dr. Manhattan would have just
incinerated them in their entirety and
that was the expectation you know from
like a bank manager from the bank
tellers the customers who were in there
they expected dr. Manhattan to just
obliterate marionette and mime in their
entirety the problem is that Manhattan
chose not to and the reason why was
because he basically realized that
marionette was pregnant now of course we
talked about this in the first video in
fact that's one of the biggest things is
hit on in the first video is that
marionette and mine had a child and they
wanted to know where it was I mean
there's a there's a point in the first
story where she's like where's my baby
yet so of course we know that you know
they they have a child together but it
is cool because one of the things it's
really kind of focused on when it comes
to Manhattan is this sort of lack of
concern about humanity this lack of
interest but one of the things that
really kind of also focuses on in the
original Watchmen is that if dr.
Manhattan is being human he's really
being human in name only in the sense
that well this is what humans would do
so that's what I will do I guess these
little you know these little tidbits of
humanity that are still somewhat part of
his person and kind of leak out here and
there so to speak but the funny thing
about this is that Adrian Veidt didn't
know that Ozymandias did not know that
marionette was pregnant Ozymandias looks
as that and says well Manhattan shows
not to kill him because there's some
kind of connection they share something
along those lines it's desperation where
Ozymandias is the smartest man in the
world what he's doing it's grass
spitting at straws the world is coming
to an end and we have to find dr.
Manhattan in order to save it he's the
only one that can do it and I'll believe
anything I need to believe in order to
find him in times of desperation people
will believe whatever they want to
believe whatever will make them more
comfortable even if that belief system
defies all forms of logic if it defies
all forms of evidence they will move
those facts aside and they will replace
those facts with their own opinions
because it makes them feel better about
the reality of the situation that's the
nature of things now the other thing
about this is that awesome Andy has also
came to the realization the dr.
Manhattan glowing blue is just a
byproduct of electrons escaping his body
but what it does is it leaves a trail
and so the argument of Ozymandias is
they can literally follow it like
breadcrumbs and they can find out where
it is that Manhattan went to because
with all the man Diaz's explorations and
his you know investigations he's found
nothing to indicate that dr. Manhattan
has moved to some other place in the
universe in the mind of Ozymandias he's
gone to a different universe presumably
the main DC universe and so if the
result is that as these bombs begin
crashing down around everyone we
ultimately end up having the Watchmen
Ozymandias and war shack alongside mime
and marionette basically teleport to the
DC Universe and it's actually kind of
cool because what it does from here is
it picks up with Bruce Wayne now one
thing I want you guys to remember is
that Doomsday Clock is believed to
basically take place after everything
that's going on so far so Doomsday Clock
takes place after all the current
stories that are going on in DC rebirth
right now after the events of dark
nights metal all is really kind of like
after all that stuff it takes place in
the future how far out we don't know we
don't know if like dark nights metal
will end and then immediately jumps into
Doomsday Clock or if there's a span of
like a month or two and then Doomsday
Clock starts we just know it takes place
in the future and the reason why we know
that is because for the most part the
attitude of society has shifted where
society you know previously embraced
superheroes society has basically turned
against superheroes they've turned
against Batman they've turned against
Superman we don't want you guys here now
again we could really attribute this to
the aftermath of Dark Knights metal for
example Barbados leading all of his
forces into the world you know when
attacking all the superheroes all the
citizens and metropolis being converted
in the doomsday Gotham City has really
kind of come crashing down during the
Gotham resistance tie-in for Dark
Knights metal all those things that are
going on we can
kind of presume that that's when that
takes place but that's all we can do is
make that presumption we don't know with
an absolute certainty that that's the
case the other half of this is that
Bruce Wayne has basically had to undergo
these sort of annual psychological tests
more or less to satisfy the Board of
Directors and the reason for this is
because of the fact that the Board of
Directors effectively believes that
Bruce Wayne is not capable of leading
his own company now the reason why this
matters is because Lex Corp is currently
in the process of trying to buy Wayne
Enterprises meaning Lex Luthor would run
everything Broin Enterprises is in
charge of now the immediate concern of
Lucius Fox as well as Bruce Wayne is if
this happens then basically the Batman
project will be exposed or it'll have to
go underground but we won't have the
resources we have now basically you'll
lose all your financial backing all your
gadgets all your little tricks all those
things those will all go out of the way
in truth it would actually see Batman
just kind of return to his to his golden
age form back in like the 1930s and 40s
when everything was pretty simple and
pretty basic I mean he still had things
like the batwing stuff like that but
what it basically means is that Batman
would no longer be the sort of fighting
force that he would be at the moment the
bat family would presumably go away
there so Gotham would just kind of be
left to whatever criminals really just
kind of take it over and run it in its
entirety versus our only real concern
here is what we just need to worry about
Batman won't worry about that first
we'll try to figure out a way to keep
that to keep that solvent but as long as
I pass these psychological tests it
doesn't really matter picking back up
with the Ozymandias Rorschach mom and
marionette of course they crash land in
Gotham City and it's cool because as
they make their way into the city itself
they travel to the public library they
start to notice a lot of similarities as
well as a lot of differences now
remember from the world of the watchmen
the way that story was written by Alan
Moore it was designed in a lot of ways
to be the real world The Watchmen was
designed to be like what would it be
like if heroes existed right now you
wouldn't have Superman flying around you
wouldn't have Green Lantern's you
wouldn't have Wonder Woman or anything
like that
the most extreme thing you would have
would be a guy like dr. Manhattan who
gained his powers from an intrinsic
field in terms of like superheroes per
se you'd have things like the Minutemen
some group that rose to prominence of
1939 you'd have people who would just be
running around as vigilantes throwing on
you know makeshift masks and different
costumes and so on and just kind of
using whatever training or whatever
martial arts they've learned to try to
keep the streets safe and so when your
Ozymandias
and you're looking around and you start
doing research on the city of Gotham
that you're in as well as the world that
you're in suddenly you start learning
about things like Superman you start
learning about things like Wonder Woman
you start learning about things like
Green Lantern you also begin to notice
these characters were fictional in your
universe and that's what Ozymandias
points out here in their world Superman
is a fictitious character he's a
comic-book superhero Wonder Woman is a
comic book superhero Green Lantern is a
comic book superhero they've gone from
one universe where those characters were
pretend to stepping into a universe
where they're real it's very Grant
Morrison in terms of how it's done and
it's actually really really intriguing
but doing some more research and doing
some more poking around in the mind of
Adrian Veidt they can't just go to any
one where they can't just go to Wonder
Woman or Superman or whoever what they
need are the smartest people and that's
for two different reasons the first is
because those smartest people would be
governed by logic and reason the second
is because of the fact that those
individuals will be able to help them
with whatever resources they need you
know using their intellect and so on and
so forth to help them achieve the goal
of tracking down and locating dr.
Manhattan and so the idea is to split up
Ozymandias himself we'll go after Lex
Luthor and war Shaq will go after Batman
so again it's cool because what this
does is it kind of bounces back and
forth between the two you basically end
up having war Shaq who shows up at Wayne
Manor manages to kind of break his way
in and then as he's going through
looking for clues and so on discovers
the clock that leads down into the
Batcave and Rorschach descends down into
the Batcave and triggers a trap set by
Bruce Wayne to alert anybody if anyone
enters the cave from there it switches
over to Ozymandias now this encounter
between Ozymandias and lex luthor is
amazing it is so cool and it's one of
the most interesting things out there
because remember with Lex Luthor he's
very arrogant in terms of how he
functions and who he is but remember
assuming this follows the events of Dark
Knight's medal and everything that goes
on and assuming all things being equal
Lex Luthor's not a bad guy here Lex
Luthor is not a villain Lex Luthor is a
guy who's still a hero but he's still
Lex Luthor he still considers himself to
be the smartest man in the world he's
still very arrogant he's still full of
hubris
he still staunchly believes he's right
in everything he does but notice this
and this is kind of the cool thing the
way that Geoff Johns writes Lex Luthor
and the way that Lex Luthor interacts
with Ozymandias you never know he was a
good guy and the reason for that is
because you're not supposed to know if
Lex Luthor's written right in DC Comics
you wouldn't know that he was a good guy
until
put on a Superman uniform and went to go
save the day and that's why it works you
know to kind of sidetrack for a second
that's why you can shift back and forth
with Lex Luthor you can have him be a
villain when new 52 picks up you can
have them become a good guy during the
story of forever evil and then you can
have them you know stay a good guy after
forever evil and the personality remains
intact the arrogance the hubris it all
stays as a cohesive part of what makes
him who he is because that's what people
like that's what people like about Lex
Luthor they like him being arrogant they
like him being like yeah I'm the
smartest man in the world like why
wouldn't I be and it's really kind of
funny because him in Ozymandias play off
of each other awesome and this is an
initial answer to the question from Lex
Luthor you know with regards to who are
you is I'm a smartest man on my world
you're the smartest man on yours and Lex
Luthor is like okay well then you're
obviously a bonehead and it's hilarious
because what is up happening is as
amanda's explains everything that
happens with regards to the original
Watchmen story and Lex Luthor's
responses and you really thought
humanity would stay together like you
thought that would be the thing that
would bring humanity together you know
you thought that you know having some
common force and the massive loss of
life would be the thing that would unite
humanity like if you're the smartest
person in the world I would hate to meet
the dumbest person in the world now
again this works beautifully it worked
so well because it's this whole idea
that Lex Luthor's just like I mean
that's not how I would have done it and
if it's not how I would have done it
then it was the wrong thing to do but
it's funny the way this exchange is done
because it's almost like Geoff Johns
basically saying Ozymandias is so far
out of his element Lex Luthor is so far
beyond Ozymandias in terms of who it is
that's smarter that it's almost comedic
speaking of comedic speaking of funny
while the two of them are basically
talking to each other of course you got
were shocked investigating the Batcave
while the two of they were talking to
one another a shot gets fired in the
office of Lex Luthor only for us to find
out that gunshot that bullet came from a
comedian how he's there I have no idea I
have no idea how the comedian's back I
have no idea where he came from
I don't even know who he is and it's
just like no way no way dude I saw that
that was like Jeff jobs man Jeff jobs
not only that you end up having
Rorschach in the Batcave and he's met by
Batman and Batman stay - you ate my
breakfast and Rorschach statement is yes
I did Batman and were Shaq meet each
other for the very first time
so Jeff John strikes again and holy hell
dude Doomsday Clock number three is so
good it is uh man it is it is incredible
it's it's it's an amazing story for
those of you guys who were just now
joining us you know if you if you're
just kind of you know hopping on this
whole bandwagon of Doomsday Clock
Doomsday Clock takes the Watchmen from
Allen war and rolls them over into the
DC Universe and the last video ended on
like a pretty massive cliffhanger which
was the return of the comedian because
as we've seen in our Watchmen video so
far the comedian died at the beginning
of the story that's kind of what set the
whole Watchmen story in motion was the
death of the comedian and so the idea is
like you know when he showed up at the
end it was okay who's playing the
comedian like who in the world is
playing the world a comedian
somebody's got to be playing his
character because I mean the comedians
dead and it can't be resurrected from
the dead right well the cool thing about
this is that it initially opens up with
like the comedian seemingly just kind of
like up hearing in the water in the DC
Universe you know out in the ocean
somewhere of course you know swim into
the surface and basically coming to and
he's met by dr. Manhattan now this is
huge this is massive on the surface it
doesn't seem that huge but this is huge
because he's wearing the exact same
outfit you know the bathrobe and
everything that he was wearing when he
originally died the indication here is
that dr. Manhattan intervened or
resurrected the comedian now I would say
dr. Manhattan probably intervened
if he resurrected the comedian then like
Eddie Blake would have just shown up
like on a street somewhere or in a
building somewhere but what it looks
like is at the time he was being thrown
out of the building when he was
basically being attacked in the
beginning of Watchmen and before he hit
the ground he was effectively teleported
away and we've seen that happen right I
mean that was a whole basis of the Oz
effect mr. Oz is the father of Superman
he was supposed to die when Krypton
exploded but instead dr. Manhattan
stepped in and whisked him away
teleported him away from Krypton and
threw him on earth and then basically
forced him to you know percenter
perceive earth and to see earth from
everything that was going on in the eyes
of you know just a normal person and so
on and so forth but
reason why this is such a big deal is
because it's been established in the
Watchmen at least in the original box
plan watch my colleagues dr. Manhattan
cannot time travel he can't travel back
and forth through Todd he can perceive
time all and you know all happening at
once and so because that it's really
intriguing because either this means he
has a new set of powers or time is
passing differently in the Watchmen
universe than it is in the main DC
universe but again it's one of those
weird mysteries that goes on we don't
know exactly how all these pieces fit
together
it is really intriguing and it is really
interesting now the other half of this
is we're not really given a time frame
of when this is that comedian landed
here we don't know if this happened 20
years ago we don't know if this happened
five years ago if it happened you know
an hour and a half ago we don't know
exactly when this took place all we know
is somewhere along the line when
comedian was falling to his death he was
whisked away by Manhattan he ended up in
the DC Universe and at this point we
pick up with his attempt to take out
Ozymandias now of course this leads to a
leads to him really you know trying to
kill Ozymandias because of everything
that happened in the whole watchmen
comic of course kind of picking up with
the idea of Doomsday Clock and so on and
so forth did the other half of this is
that Lex Luthor was kind of caught in
the crossfire right like the killing
shot meant for Ozymandias was you know
ended up hitting Lex Luthor instead but
the fight that breaks out is pretty
intense and it's very reminiscent of
what we would expect in this kind of a
situation comedian versus dr. Manhattan
I'm sorry a comedian versus versus you
know Ozymandias and it is pretty
intriguing because remember Ozymandias
is supposedly one of the fastest people
our lives if not the fastest man alive
in Watchmen because he was able to like
catch bullets and so on and so forth the
reaction time was unbelievable but again
it's kind of crazy because you know
Eddie Blake starts talking about things
like how death changes a man but again
it's it's it's kind of a mystery here we
don't know how all this stuff fits
together now of course you know
Ozymandias is able to make his escape
Lex Luthor's kind of left behind
oxidized oh man is is injured in the
fall then at that point we pick up with
Rorschach and Batman and that was really
like the biggest cliffhanger of issue
number two was war Shaq meeting Batman
for the first time but remember this is
not Walter or this is not you know
Walter corvex I know I keep saying
corvex but it's been hinted right off
the bat or is at least we've been told
white off the bat this is not the
original Rorschach
the two of them meeting each other is
really intriguing and so it's really
kind of Jeff John's hitting home at this
idea of saying hey look this person is
not the original war Shaq but he does
have possession of war shacks journal
and this is cool because he basically
passes this information to Batman
passionate the journal to him and says
you need to read this you need to read
this journal and everything entailed
within it now at this point we pick up
with marionette and mine now remember
marionette and mime are like the old
Charlton comic characters again closely
guys who are relatively new while Marvel
and DC do stand is like the biggest and
most popular coming for publishers right
now with like value in an image in a
really really close second what you also
had back in like way back in the day
really before Marvel became Marvel back
when it was like Atlas and maybe even
timely as you had Charlton publications
and Charlton created a lot of characters
Blue Beetle different things like that
and a lot of those characters are just
kind of rolled over into DC when DC
bought Charlton just because the fact
that Charlton couldn't keep up with DC
in terms of sales but marionette and
mime are these are you know kind of a
tribute to these old Charlton characters
a design to kind of be a homage to these
old superheroes from back in the day but
for the most part when they when they
popped up people immediately got the
vibe of like the Joker and Harley Quinn
and it's designed to be that way and the
reason why is because when they've been
thrust into the DC Universe they show up
in Gotham City and it's really
intriguing here because once they get
into Gotham well then the question
becomes you know what is this place
let's explore the city and let's see
what's going on they basically make
their way to a to a bar of sorts which
is the Joker's bar and this is cool
because the Joker you know one thing to
keep in mind when it comes to to DC
Comics the Joker has these different
little places here and there use
different places he operates out of a
way to kind of build as revenue
different things like that to kind of
make sure that this stream of money
flows to a degree or at least to always
access henchmen and it is interesting
because marionette and mine don't know
who the Joker is but it is funny because
a fight inevitably breaks out here when
they kind of show up and they're like
look we don't know who the Joker isn't
we don't really care we end up having
mine basically pull an invisible gun now
this is all new to me I mean this this
is new for the most part I mean this is
office is really like uncharted water
where previously it was believed at mine
wielding like invisible weapons or at
least mining weapons what he actually
has our invisible weapons he's got an
invisible gun he's got invisible daggers
and he actually shoots a person with
this invisible gun it's really cool and
it's really really intriguing because it
kind of throws people off you have a guy
who walks in here and it looks like he's
got a gun in his hand but in reality you
don't see anything but then suddenly the
trigger gets pulled as a flash of light
and somebody's brains are all over the
other side of the room so it's really
really interesting now of course these
two one of the things that that the
Geoff Johns hit home is the idea that
they're very sadistic they're designed
to be reminiscent of what we would
expect with the Joker and Harley Quinn
and so they tear all these guys apart
and they they literally crush every
single one of these guys and with
everybody having been taken out
everybody having been you know more or
less killed off the question they have
is who's this joker guy and let's go
find out who he is let's go see what's
going on with this Joker fella it's
really intriguing and it's super
interesting now from here we basically
pick up with well really with a lot of
ways Johnny Thunder and this is kind of
a big deal now Johnny Thunder is a
character that we've talked about before
and he really kind of had his big moment
only really a couple of appearance
appearance is so far I want to say one
was in the button and the other one was
in DC Universe rebirth number one but
Johnny Thunder is a throwback to like
one of DC's oldest characters he really
is I mean he goes all the way back to
flash comics number one in 1940 so he's
been around for a long long time now in
truth the reason why Johnny Thunder is
so significant here or at least the
reason why I think they're invoking his
character is because Johnny Thunder is a
character that's in possession of what
amounts to basically a genie I want to
say his pronounces is it's like it's
like Y Z or something like that but it's
basically called a thunderbolt when
Johnny Thunder accesses this power he
basically becomes a reality warper like
it's insane how powerful he is he can do
virtually anything he wants to now this
is all pre-crisis stuff I mean this is
all stuff back from like you know
all-star comics number 42 in like 1948
and this is all old-school stuff before
crisis on Infinite Earths
now DC could grab it and they could roll
it over but Johnny Thunder as we see him
here being an old man all indications is
that the post-crisis landscape for
Johnny Thunder is still intact me
he doesn't really have the Thunderbolt
power anymore he doesn't really have the
power of the genie anymore but it
doesn't mean that he can't it doesn't
mean that it's not possible for that to
happen we've seen him you know have it
originally then we saw him lose it
Hakeem picked it up who was basically a
post-crisis character that was designed
to kind of reinvigorate and reinvent the
character of Johnny Thunder or at least
the concept of the Thunderbolt um
eventually Johnny Thunder is kind of you
know basically died and then of course
he came back to her in blackest night
but the fact remains that I mean it's
entirely possible that even if he's not
necessarily the one that would be in
possession of the is genie the
Thunderbolt power it doesn't mean he
can't get into contact who we know with
those who can but it is intriguing
because again we're talking about a guy
who has reality-warping power or at
least with the is genie would have
reality-warping power now all that
brings in a sharp relief the question if
the that power is that strong then like
what hope would it would they have even
against talking about hatton anyway
because the power of the genie was
basically equal to the power of mr.
Mixel pedelec but we saw in Superman
reborn that mr. Bixler pedelec was
terrified of dr. Manhattan I mean that
was one of the things that was fleshed
out that Mister you know Mitchell
petal-like had at some point in time
come into contact with Manhattan and
realized that even with all his reality
were in power Mixel pedelec was
basically dwarfed by the power that dr.
Manhattan had so again it really kind of
begs the question what hope do they have
but if they do have a reality warper on
their side then conceivably they stand a
better chance than just kind of Superman
fighting against dr. Manhattan and
hoping for the best now this also brings
into sharp relief the nature of the JSA
right the Justice Society of America you
know that was really kind of like DC's
way of answering the question why is it
that Jay Garrick the original flash
doesn't exist anymore in DC said well I
mean you know all the superhero stories
where you see Barry Allen running around
as a flash that all takes place on earth
one all the superhero stories where you
see Jay Garrick as the flash that's all
on earth too and it was pretty simple
for a time anyway until really about ten
years later when I just turned into
absolute madness but it's
well-established that for the most part
geoff johns loves the Silver Age of
comics and rightfully so because back
then it was really more of like
light-hearted superhero fare as opposed
to now when the stories are a little
more gritty and a little more reflective
of the nature of the world that we
Livan and so with the return of the JSA
it would almost seem like this kind of
missing link in DC Comics would sort of
be rounded out it would be like if
Marvel brought the Fantastic Four back
there's something about the DC Universe
that's just not right it's just kind of
missing that one thing that really kind
of sets it all off you know Shazam is
another character who's missing Martian
Manhunter there's a handful of things
that are out there that would help to
kind of complete the DC Universe in the
eyes of fans but in terms of the impact
of the Justice Society it's bringing an
era of comics where hope is really the
name of the game that was the base that
was the way it was with the JSA and when
you look at things where it's like well
because of the Superman theory and
because of the fact that you know 97% of
all the superheroes originated on earth
and because you have all these different
you know programs out there the Russian
government that's using you know they're
kind of metahuman testing to basically
weed out people and arrest them and they
believe to be metahumans it's almost
like this idea that Jon's is kind of
going back to his you know they're kind
of Infinite Crisis roots where this is a
criticism of superhero stories essays
this now I wouldn't say this is as
heavy-handed is Infinite Crisis but I
will say that it's kind of hitting at
the idea that either the DC Universe is
kind of going down the same path as The
Watchmen in the sense of the earth is
kind of on a collision course for
self-destruction or it's a criticism of
the idea that the world kind of seems
hopeless at the moment in the DC
universe that things are pretty dark and
what the DC Universe needs is a spark of
light they need something to kind of say
hey look guys it's not as bad as you
think it is and having old man Flash Jay
Garrick you know having old man Green
Lantern Alan Scott having these
characters just kind of show up and
basically be this kind of beacon where
they sort of set the landscape and
they're kind of these other superheroes
that embody the hopeful concepts of
Superman
would really kind of beef that up a bit
that kind of seems to be what Geoff
Johns is hitting out here now again
that's speculation online on body half
it's not really anything guaranteed is
not a solidified thing it's just kind of
how I look at it and interpret it
because you know as a person who is
really relatively new to DC I will say
that from what I've seen with people
commenting it feels like something is
kind of missing and maybe that JSA is
you know the key maybe it's that little
puzzle piece that would sort of flush
things out in their entirety at this
point we switch back over to Rorschach
and again in this story were shocked is
taking up residence in Gotham I'm sorry
and not though in Wayne Manor only
temporarily but what we end up getting
is the reveal of his face now we don't
get a name here all we get is a reveal
of his face and the indication is that
he is actually the son of Malcolm long
that he is actually the son of the
psychiatrist of the original workshop
but we're not given a name
so we don't know for sure the indication
seems to be the play it seems to be the
case you know we knew that Malcolm long
had a son Malcolm long and his wife are
both african-american clearly this
version of of Rorschach is
african-american we knew that just
because of the reveal of his hand but of
course with the face and everything we
also know that's an absolute certainty
the clues are there and it really kind
of seems to be thrown in our face but it
could also be a red herring so again
until a name is dropped we're not given
an absolute certainty but you know that
kind of seems to be the case which we
can probably run with that we could
probably take that as some measure of a
gospel truth but the fact remains here
what we end up having is Batman going
through the entirety of the original war
shock journal and basically meeting with
you know this this new war shack once he
wakes up after having slept for like 24
hours and it's intriguing because Batman
basically says hey look I think I know
where this guy's at like I know where
dr. Manhattan is we have to go find dr.
Manhattan and it's really really cool
because what ends up happening is he
says look I think this guy is in this
facility over here so like we need to go
check this out I'm pretty sure I know
where he is he leaves were shocked to
this location opens the door Rorschach
walks in and all there is is writing on
a back wall that says we're all mad here
and Batman shuts the door behind him and
says look I'm sorry but you belong in
here
we end up finding out this place is
Arkham Asylum that Batman believes
Rorschach is a crazy person and as a
result just locks him up and throws away
the key and that's what's so interesting
about this is because Rorschach's not
crazy and he is to a degree assuming
that this guy is anything like the
original Walter Kovacs like he is kind
of crazy to a degree but it doesn't mean
he's wrong a broken clock is Right twice
a day and this guy's basically coming
with news saying hey look the end is at
hand the end is nigh there's a being
walking around in your universe that
Dwarfs all the power that you have the
events that you experienced in the
button that death of eobard
on being able to see your father you
know this mysterious power source out
there that destroyed the White Lantern
Corps I know what it is and I know what
it's capable of but Batman doesn't
believe any of it to be true he doesn't
really think any of it's legit and
ultimately it kind of calls it a day
Bruce Wayne has not connected the dots
now the question becomes what happens
when he does okay so we are officially
picking up with Doomsday Clock part four
I know it's been a little while since
we've covered Doomsday Clock it's being
released like bimonthly now which is
really disappointing because the story
so good and like I'm always on the edge
like like dude I really want to know
what happens next but we are on part for
it and this is the origin of like the
new Rorschach and this is kind of cool
because what this is going to do is
basically prove me wrong and prove a lot
of people right and I know those are
lower or those of you guys who were part
of my channel who were just like I don't
care what happens as long as Rob is
wrong so like it's it's fine it's not a
huge deal to me it doesn't really matter
to me but this is cool because this
gives us like the origin of this new
version I remember playing a little bit
of catch-up for those of you guys who
were you know just now jumping into
things or who have forgotten the idea is
that that Geoff Johns is kind of
blending the DC Universe with the
Watchmen universe and we didn't know who
this version of war Shack was all we
knew was that war shack had just popped
up inside of the Doomsday Clock stories
and of course we knew it wasn't like the
original Walter corvax because he died
at the end of Watchmen and so in this
the questioner buddy had was who is this
new version of work Shack what in the
world is going on here
and so what this does and it's a little
a little confusing at first because it
actually kind of bounces back and forth
because of the fact that this version of
war shack had basically appeared in the
Batcave had made his way in there and
then ultimately was you know taken by
that man and tricked him to Arkham
Asylum he's basically just been residing
here ever since but what it does is it
jumps back and forth between the past
and the present
now it's designed to be this way Geoff
Johns has been writing comic book
stories long enough that if his
intention is not to like create
bewilderment then he won't create it and
so the fact that this story is just kind
of like bouncing around and almost
leaving us with a state of confusion in
terms of what's happening in the present
was happening in the past that's
designed to be the nature of like the
Rorschach character his mind is quite
literally a wreck it's absolutely
decimated in so many different ways and
the reason for this is because what we
do is we initially pick up when he was
younger basically he's the son of
Malcolm long he's the son of the
psychologist that was analyzing Walter
Kovacs analyzing the original Rorschach
and picking up with him will be
finding out is that when his father
essentially took on the case of Walter
there were a lot of things that were
going on in the background that you know
were shacks what it's called Moore Shack
for the sake of it there were sharks mom
was really kind of an estate like she
was struggling because her husband was
becoming more and more distant and that
was in the original watchman comic like
that's the way that story originally
went down is that Malcolm long became
more and more separated from his family
it became an obsession the desire to
learn about war Shack and the desire to
learn what made war Shack tick what made
the original Walter Kovacs tick that
became like the drive of of Malcolm
I'm sorry Malcolm long himself of
Reggie's dad and so because that it
eventually drove a wedge between
Reggie's mom and Reggie's father but we
didn't know the effect that it had on
Reggie and initially it didn't have a
huge one it didn't have a massive effect
on him he was just kind of watching
things that were going on and he was
sort of looking at these protests and so
on and so forth but all that changed in
the attack on New York when this monster
was unleashed in this huge psychic
backlash just swept across the city and
killed three some odd million people and
had this massive effect on him because
what it did is it drove him insane it
drove him crazy he was one of the
survivors of this whole incident he was
rescued by the cops he was taken to an
insane asylum and that was really about
it he was kind of left there in fact he
was taken to the same institution that
Mothman was taken to you in the Watchmen
comic so before the Watchmen comic
started and so while the two of them
were occupying his cell what we end up
having is we end up having this guy dr.
Matthew Mason who shows up and this is
kind of cool because what geoff johns
does is he puts on this kind of show
that like the cycle repeats itself that
walter corvax basically becomes a
vigilante he goes crazy he ends up
getting caught on he ends up being
thrown into an institution and then you
end up having like like Malcolm longer
shows up I'm not gonna long interviews
them and then Malcolm long starts to
become the new Rorschach and that drives
a wedge in his family this cycle repeats
itself here of course Reggie's not
married he doesn't have any children of
his own but still the the after effects
the impact of what Rorschach is and what
it stands for is almost like this sort
of virus that spreads throughout things
and even Reggie himself is having like
these hallucinations he's losing his
mind he's seeing like the eye of the
monster in the forehead of Matthew Mason
this is the nature of things and that's
why this story can get a little bit
confusing because it bounces back and
forth between the past and the present
but again this is designed to tell the
story of how it was that Reggie long met
Adrian Veidt and so in his effort to
basically escape this mental institution
what he does he incapacitates one of the
guards when they show up with food or
what-have-you and then takes off to the
roof of the building to try to get away
and in truth it's really one of these
things of like I just want to get away
from all this like I want
be out of here this is not where I
belong but when he gets up there he
basically ends up meeting Mothman and
Mothman statement is like I'm flying
away I'm getting out of this place I
don't need to be here I'm perfectly sane
and he literally puts on like a moth
suit we're really just kind of like
winged he's like makeshift wings made
out of bedsheets really and then just
flies away into the moon where Reggie's
basically taken by the security guards
and brought back to the institution
itself now shortly after this this is
where things get cool shortly after this
uh you end up having Mothman who's
essentially caught by the cops what he's
just outside of like this diner and then
he's brought back to the asylum and him
and Reggie begin this sort of not really
a father-son relationship but they begin
like a friendly relationship they start
talking to each other all the time
now for Byron Byron Lewis he was a
really interesting concept in the
watchman's stories I mean he came from a
life of privilege like he never really
struggled financially and for him like
being a superhero initially was more
like hey let's just go have fun it was
more like an adventurous sort of thing
now that began to change when he joined
groups like the Minuteman and then he
stepped into the role of saying well
let's actually do some good in the world
different things like that the issue is
that in the Watchmen comics because the
Age of Heroes wasn't met in the same way
it was and like DC or marvel in the
sense that like superheroes were
effectively shunned not really
superheroes the people who dressed in
costumes a really kind of shunned
eventually what ended up happening is
like when the whole anti you know
superhero era came along when the whole
anti mask era came along and even during
the height of McCarthyism what you had
was Byron who basically succumb to like
alcoholism as a result of like all the
dangers and perils that went into being
a superhero and so the result was that
he was confined to a mental asylum in
Maine which seems to be where this whole
thing is going on but the idea here is
that he was always an exceedingly smart
guy and for him it was a matter of like
putting the pieces together and looking
around and seeing everything that was
going on and where he is a person that
plays the role of a friend to Reggie
what he ends up doing is he actually
manages to gather a whole bunch of
Malcolm Long's belongings and bring them
to Reggie he basically gives his son his
father's things and so the result is
that Reggie starts going through and
looking at like the Journal of Rorschach
looking at the notes of his father
listening to the recordings all these
things and as time progresses because of
the fact that Reggie is in such a
fractured fragile mental state Woody
ends up doing is actually adopting the
persona and the personality of were
shocked now again this is cool because
what you have John's kind of teases here
and really what Allen wore was sort of
shooting for was that anybody could be
war shot that was the point of the mask
anybody could be behind that mask but
that's the basis behind that's why
superheroes were perceived to be so
dangerous is because nobody knew who
they were
you're a copy editor by day and like a
vigilante by night just smashing
people's heads in and breaking their
fingers and thumbs and hands like that's
that's the whole thing that went behind
that and so for Reggie like he kind of
stands with this embodiment of war shock
in the sense that at the end of the day
Walter Kovacs was just a guy who had
enough in his mind it was a matter of
trying to find a way to curb the
violence so to speak you know being the
killer who kills killers if that makes
any sense
and so with Reggie being in that state
being you know basically like victimized
by the various authorities who were
there the orderlies inside the insane
asylum being treated like crap he just
kind of falls down tumbles down into
this path of Rorschach tumbles down into
the role of Walter Kovacs not only that
it's almost I wouldn't see how as far as
to say it's a little bit of manipulation
but I would go as far as to say that
when it comes to Mothman is intriguing
because what he says is he he starts
going through and like there's this
puzzle they're working on and the puzzle
is ultimately the face of Ozymandias and
it's him basically saying if you know
how to look at this picture of the right
way then you know what's going on and
that's what happened with Reggie Reggie
just started putting all the pieces
together he looked at the Journal of
Walter Kovacs everything that was going
on and said like this is the fault of
Adrian Veidt it was always the falter of
Adrian Veidt initially he was kind of
trying to figure things out and trying
to work on things until he got to the
end of the journal of Walter Kovacs when
Walter Kovacs basically says like Adrian
Veidt is the reason behind all this and
that's the funny thing is because no one
else has quite figured this out yet and
the newsreels there's indications
there's there's you know people who were
like speculating and saying well it
seems like it's Adrian Veidt and super
you know smart scientists and things
like that people who are trying to
answer the question of what was going on
social psychologists and what-have-you
are analysing like everything that was
taking place and saying well all the
clues seem to point to Adrian Veidt but
Reggie long is the only person that has
incontrovertible proof that Adrian Veidt
was behind it all and that's where he
full-on steps into the role of were
shocked because now what he does is he
looks around and says there's a guy out
there they killed three million people
what would war Shack have done what
would Walter Kovacs have done well
Walter Kovacs would have killed him
that's what Walter Kovacs believed
needed to be done that Adrian Veidt had
to be stopped so I'm going to pick up
the slack I'm gonna continue on this
mission of Walter Kovacs I'm going to
kill Adrian Veidt and at this point it
just breaks down to the question of how
can it be done how can it be pulled off
and this is when people begin to start
realizing that adrian veidt's the one
behind all this that's when it really
began to go topsy-turvy because remember
when it came to light
the time gap between the watchmen comics
and the Doomsday Clock comics we don't
have anything to fill in that gap all we
have is what's been told to us by Geoff
Johns and like what interviews have been
done and what speculation exists on the
Internet but by and large this answers
that question it tells us that like at
the end of Watchmen the world was united
in response to like this giant monster
that killed three million people in New
York the world was united in mourning
and the world looked to make the world a
better place because people began to
realize how fragile they were and then
the information came out that Adrian
Veidt was behind it all and then that
fragility shattered and the world was
worse off than it was before Veidt went
through this whole scheme of unleashing
this monster in New York you know
because people realize they've been
tricked
they'd been duped it wasn't an actual
piece and so in light of all this what
Reggie does is he actually sets a fire
inside the institution and where he and
Mothman are gonna leave and go find
Adrian instead Mothman goes back into
the building as someone just allows
himself to die and so then you have
Reggie who just takes on the whole war
shaq mantle and goes to find Adrian
Veidt who's basically on the Percy buys
this tanker out in the middle of nowhere
but when he gets there it's intriguing
and this is where we start to get like
the reggie personality and the worshop
personality who are a little in conflict
when Reggie shows up to kill Adrian
Veidt Adrian Veidt just kind of turns
around and says look you can kill me if
you want to but like I'm dying anyway
like it's only a matter of time before I
die like there's there's nothing that
could be done I've basically got brain
cancer and it's kind of cool here
because in truth like if Adrian Veidt
were going to die anyway of what purpose
would be served by Rorschach killing him
this kind of the stance that ready takes
work shot kills people who would
otherwise be able to continue on their
normal lives just doing whatever it is
they want to do all the time but for
Adrian Veidt he's not really a criminal
he's not really a bad guy and that's the
reason why this this whole situation
works that's the reason why this is so
cool one of the classic examples in a
situation like this is the trolley train
right like you're a trolley conductor
and the brakes go out on the other
brakes go out and all you have at your
control is like the steering column and
you can steer the trolley on one of two
sets of tracks on one set of tracks is
one construction worker and he's totally
oblivious has no idea this Charlie train
is just hurtling towards him is gonna
smash into him and and and kill him
entirely but if you steer it to the
other tracks there's five construction
workers you have to choose between one
or the other which one do you choose
will you choose the one construction
worker you kill that one guy in order to
save those five guys it's utilitarianism
and when you're Adrian Veidt and you're
looking around and you say humanity
there's there's seven you know seven
some odd billion
people are six or five or whatever then
the absolute number count was at the
time the story was written when you have
however many billions of people in the
world who are all going to be destroyed
because the clock is inching ever closer
to nuclear war between the u.s. and the
USSR then like what steps do you take to
unite people people don't unite
willingly anymore it doesn't work that
way people have to be united when
there's like a massive catastrophe what
he needed was a catalyst he needed
something that would force humanity to
unite because they had to not because
they wanted to and so that's what that
monster was the monster showed up in the
city of New York it killed three million
of some odd people and it was like oh my
god you know the the terrible situation
this is so awful you know in the
humanity and so on and so forth but in
light of how terrible things were and
the massive amount of casualties
humanity United and that was the goal of
Adrian Veidt what he didn't pay
attention to and what he didn't think
about was the aftermath and that's the
cool thing here is because this goes
into that whole moral philosophy like
like what what makes an act good is it
you know the consequence or is it the
act itself you know is it the intention
behind the act if adrian veidt's
intention was to unite humanity and make
the world a better place he's a good guy
if all you care about is the consequence
the world's worse off after what he did
than it was before he did what he did
then he's a bad guy he made things
terrible but that's the difference here
Adrian Veidt wasn't looking to rob
people
he wasn't looking to unleash a monster
in New York and then steal everybody's
valuables while they were all distracted
he was trying to make the world a
legitimate better place and so because
of that like you kind of have to have
pity on him and that's where he sort of
began to give up that's where he looked
around and said if humanity really
wanted to unite it would have if people
really wanted to solve the world's
problems then they would have but they
don't want to solve the world's problems
they want to goose-step themselves into
nuclear war between the u.s. and the
USSR there's nothing that could be done
whatever happens happens and that's why
he teamed up with with Reggie long and
that's why I said we have to go find dr.
Manhattan we have to bring him back what
will happen when they do we don't know
Manhattan might show up and say well
humanity's gonna kill itself anyway so
I'll just help them on help them along a
little bit and just wipe away the world
there's any number of things that could
go on and in like the whole Watchmen
universe so because of that what we
ended up doing is with the two of them
teaming up and that of course is where
Doomsday Clock number one picks up we
jump back to the modern day here in
issue number four after Reggie had been
thrown into Arkham Asylum by Bruce Wayne
and so one is um happening here is
basically he has a conversation with
what appears to be Saturn girl from
to superheroes because she's been locked
up in Arkham Asylum the entire time
that's where she's been this whole time
that was teased back in DC universe
rebirth number one and so what she says
is like we have to get out of here like
we have to make our escape she's already
out like she's literally out of herself
and just roaming around and she's like
we have to get out of here
you know because I don't have that much
time and whatever is coming is gonna
require like the entire superhero
community if we don't work together
we're all going to dot and that's what's
cool because it's basically saying like
dr. Manhattan is coming here it's only a
matter of time before he does and so the
two of them basically team up and who
knows what happens at that you know I'm
about to find out the next issue what we
also end up finding out and this is a
cool indication here what seems to have
happened is that dr. Matthew Mason was a
fictional person he didn't exist
instead it looks it looks like it was
Alfred Pennyworth although I still think
it's Batman but it looks like it was
Alfred Pennyworth who was disguised as
Matthew Mason who went walking into the
insane asylum pretending to be a
psychologist trying to understand who
wore shuck is and that makes sense
Batman's not gonna take that person
throw him into Arkham Asylum and then
just throw away the key and never ever
ask any questions that it doesn't work
like that it's always the significance
of gathering information finding out as
much as you can as often as you can and
that's exactly what's been going on here
they've basically been investigating
Reggie long without him knowing it and
so that's where the question becomes
will Batman side with Reggie or will
batman stand against Reggie okay so we
are continuing on with Doomsday Clock a
lot of you guys have been asking where
the Doomsday Clock videos have been the
story comes out every other month now
although I believe they've backed it up
so that now that it's monthly but it's
one of those weird things where it was
supposed to be monthly you were supposed
to last a full year and the way that DC
seemed to be going is you had like the
DC rebirth initiative and it was like
the rebirth initiative would end when
this whole thing picked up basically
when when Doomsday Clock concluded that
would go into the next phase of DC but
because it's been backed up it looks
like it'll stretch on for three years so
I have no idea comes out four times a
year and it's 12 issues long so so yes
it's kind of crazy it's a weird
situation but we basically end up
picking up of course you know in in the
aftermath of the last one now one thing
to bear in mind here is that this really
is like Geoff Johns vision like Geoff
Johns and Gary Frank which by the way
Gary Frank man this guy is just stupidly
talented but it really fits into like
the vision of what they have you know
like if the watchmen met the DC Universe
they saw this whole thing fits in but
with Adrian Veidt when they crossed over
into the DC landscape
initially like he went to go check out
Lex Luthor and then of course Rorschach
went to go check out Batman and the
result was that Rorschach was basically
thrown in Arkham Asylum by Batman
because it was like this guy's illusion
this guy's absolutely nutso of course
Batman
ended up following up pretending to be
an interviewer in order to get an
understanding of Rorschach's mind but
what you had is Adrian Veidt who
basically took a bullet for Lex Luthor
when he was shot at by the comedian and
again it was a wafer for John to just
start bringing in all these different
characters and so on so what this does
is it basically picks up immediately
after or not really immediately but it
picks up shortly after all this with
Adrian Veidt in a hospital and so of
course he's basically being guarded here
and the perception is that Adrian Veidt
seems to be a metahuman there's no
actual indication that's the case and in
fact Adrian Veidt himself doesn't
actually have any powers but the reason
why he's perceived to be a metahuman is
because of the outfit he was wearing he
was basically dressed as a costume
superhero and so it was assumed he was a
costumed superhero and his powers were
just unknown and so with there being
additional security of course Adrian
Veidt basically wakes up and then
attracts the attention of a couple of
guards by making it appear as though
he's flatlined and then subdue them now
this is cool because this is like the
small little things that go into what
Geoff Johns does right like Geoff Johns
is one of these guys who's like a master
storyteller when it comes to crafting
comic book stories like him and Jonathan
Hickman are like my two favorite comic
book writers of all time with Scott
Snyder and Al Ewing at a close second so
it's it's cool when it comes to this
whole thing because it's a way to
basically say like here's why Adrian
Veidt is so interesting is because his
capabilities are universal like it
doesn't matter what he like what
universe he's in his intelligence is
there but from here of course he grabs
Bubastis basically takes off out of the
hospital and then goes about his own
business and so from here we switch over
to Lois Lane now again this is why I
love John's writing so much is because
everybody gets a little piece of this
pie right like everybody's in this whole
thing and the whole gist behind this is
that it's all really focused on the
Superman theory now again for those of
you guys who are really this is kind of
what you're jumping into with this one
one I would highly suggest that you guys
go back in and watch the other videos or
buy the other comics and - the whole
idea of the Superman theory is that
someone somewhere had basically drawn
the conclusion that all the superheroes
in the DC universe or at least a huge
brunt of them originated from the United
States and so where they do have their
own origin stories a lot of their origin
stories are cloak and dagger in a lot of
different ways someone as iconic as
Superman is more well-known but Batman
is
an enigma no one really knows Batman's
Bruce Wayne outside of the bat family no
one really knows what goes on with his
character and you have all these
different superheroes who exist around
the landscape you know and even super
villains and they're really a mystery to
a lot of people and so because of that
theories began to arise the most
prominent of which is that the federal
government is creating metahumans and so
what you end up having is you have Lois
Lane who's really just kind of speaking
with Clark Kent about the whole thing
and then in turn she basically goes to
visit Lex Luthor who of course is in the
hospital as well and the encounter
between the two is actually really
really intriguing here because it's her
really just kind of breaking down and
going through step by step and it's even
like Lex Luthor himself doing the same
thing now Lex Luthor really the kind of
revelation that gets dropped here at
least from Lex Luthor's perspective is
what he tells Lois Lane while Superman's
listening to the whole thing is he's
like look I don't know everything about
the Superman the Superman theory but the
whole point of Lois is that she believes
Luthor is at the center of it and that
works because remember this version of
Lois Lane is from a quote-unquote
previous universe but the Lex Luthor
she's familiar with is the mastermind
the bad guy the guy who's always pulling
the strings and so when she sees this
Lex Luthor and she sees something like
the Superman conspiracy her thought is
Lex Luthor has to be behind it but the
response of Lex Luthor is I'm not
pulling any strings I have nothing to do
with this I don't even know how far down
this rabbit hole goes the only thing
that I can tell you with any real
measure of certainty is that one whoever
it is is helping the federal government
humans is a metahuman themselves and two
they used to be a member of the Justice
League now one of the theme to good to
kind of bear in mind is that Geoff Johns
plays it fast and loose and that's kind
of the cool thing is you throws out this
possibility that maybe it really is all
just smoke and mirrors that maybe Lex
Luthor is just kind of full of hoo-ha
juice he doesn't really even know what's
going on he's putting on a show to make
it look like he's still you know Lex
Luthor is he's always been and all that
kind of good stuff and so it works for
what it is and it is pretty intriguing
but at this point we pick up with a
couple of things that are going on oh
really
one of the most notable is something
that involves a guy by the name of
Johnny Thunder now we talked about him
before in one of the previous videos the
idea was that Johnny Thunder basically
was in possession of like a genie or a
demon of sorts whatever you wanted to
call it but basically like when that
aspect of his personality came out he
was crazy powerful and that's the funny
thing here is he's an older man now and
it's really been that way ever since
crisis on Infinite Earths right like
you had Johnny Thunder back in the day
and he was like a really really powerful
character back before 1985 and then when
DC rebooted back in 1985 with crisis on
Infinite Earths Johnny Thunder came back
but he wasn't in the same capacity
instead he was just kind of like an
older guy who was there and so picking
up with with Adrian Veidt of course he
travels back to basically whether it
were the the vessel first cross or they
were flying the ship of night owl which
again by the way there's a handful of
characters that we haven't seen here yet
night owl we don't really know where he
is we have no idea where like Sally
Jupiter is these are characters that are
basically just mi-8 and we don't really
know what's going on but of course he
basically travels back to his ship and
he's met by Batman Batman of course has
had the the the I guess the Journal of
worship this entire time and he's like
I've read everything about you I know
all about you now this is the first time
that Adrian Veidt and Batman actually
meet and there's going to be an amazing
conversation that goes on between the
two of them here in the next little
while but something else that I also
want to draw your attention to is Saturn
girl now of course we saw in like the
last story the last little tidbit here
that Saturn girl was one of the people
who had been housed inside of Arkham
Asylum and she'd been there ever since
rebirth kicked off and presumably even
before that but she was just Jane Doe
nobody really knew anything about her
and that makes sense because Saturn girl
is part of the Legion of super-heroes
you know this 30th 31st century team
that exists in the future and it's
basically like that universe or I guess
that futures iteration of the Justice
League
now the Legion of super-heroes is
something that we haven't really talked
about before but they have a huge
following but the whole idea that Legion
of super-heroes in DC Comics was one of
these sort of combination testbeds as
well as trying to figure out what to do
next in a sense that back in really the
the 1940s you had the stories of
Superboy and the stories of Superboy
were designed to basically say here's
what Superman was doing between the time
that he first arrived on earth and the
time that he traveled to Metropolis and
became Superman but DC started to run
into problems these problems included
things like continuity airs the origin
of a villain that Superman faces off
against is told in Johanna Superboy but
the origin and Superboy does not match
the origin in Superman the other half of
this was that you can only ever really
tell so many stories about Superboy's
antics before even at that point in time
it stretches the limits of credulity and
so the question was what else can we do
with this character and so because
Superboy was so popular DC brought in
the Legion of super-heroes and then
eventually sent Superboy off with the
team
basically allies it would face off
against various threats and the
popularity of Superboy elevated the
popularity of the Legion of super-heroes
and that led to them becoming some of
the most I really like one of the most
iconic teams that DC's had a long time
it's almost like this trifecta the
Justice League the Legion of
super-heroes and the Teen Titans but the
idea is that Saturn girls basically here
and this is really the first time that
we see geoff johns addressing the fact
that it is Saturn girl now that was
thrown out in in DC Universe rebirth
number one but since then she really
hasn't been referenced as Saturn girl
but Saturn girl has the ability to read
minds and so when she's going through
and and really you know I guess reading
the mind of Rorschach that's when we
start getting into things like Sally
Jupiter as when we start getting into
like all these different variations of
characters that exist in the Watchmen
universe that we would expect to see
here we haven't seen them and there's no
information about where they went to but
we do know that like in some former
fashion they probably do exist and so
again from here we switch over to
marionette and her husband now again
these are basically like these old
charlton characters but the fact that
Geoff Johns rolled them into this story
as soon as they made their appearance we
knew right off the bat that we're gonna
run into the Joker it was only ever a
matter of time what we know is that when
they started showing up as soon as they
arrived in Gotham City as soon as they
landed here they started seeing these
various villains or these various
henchmen who are running around dressed
as clowns and their question was who are
these guys and why are they dressed as
clowns and the more they investigated
the more they basically learned about
the Joker and so that's when their
question was who's the Joker who is this
guy we want to meet him and see what
he's about we're gonna put into the test
and hopefully hopefully we're gonna find
him wanting like that's that's what
they're shooting for here and that's
what they've been doing all this time we
want the Joker and the best way to get
the Joker's attention is to take what he
desires most and that's literally what
they've been doing they've been going
through and causing all kinds of
problems robbing various places busting
in to Joker's facilities so on and so
forth just different things like that
and so the result here is that we
basically pick up with really with like
Ozymandias Adrian Veidt and Batman
having this conversation as they're
essentially traveling around and they're
basically heading out to you know
wherever it is they're heading out to
and as they have this conversation it's
amazing because really like Adrian Veidt
raises like this concern that I've been
arguing the entire time that Batman and
really like the DC superhero landscape
as a whole and even like extending that
to like Marvel Comics what adrian
veidt's says is like on my
on my earth I made everything better
like I wind us off of oil I weaned us
off of gasoline I basically improve the
world in a variety of different ways
nuclear disarmament these are all things
that were done by efforts that I put in
but here you are a guy who dresses as a
bat and beats up people in the middle of
the night and your city is no better off
than it was before you ever became a
superhero in the first place that
Superman is really the only person who's
been able to land in a city take up
residence there and make it safer just
because Superman so hot so powerful but
the responsive Adrian Veidt is your your
efforts are useless like you serve no
real purpose here you don't do any good
for the city of Gotham
you're just another wrench in the works
and that's it and so that that's when he
kind of asked the question what have you
ever done to make the world a better
place
how was the world better off now than it
was before you showed up and as in this
is a cool situation because it's not the
world really like Gotham City is not a
better place than before Batman got
there Batman hasn't done anything he
hasn't done any good he's a dog chasing
its tail and that's what invite really
kind of brings up the idea of dr.
Manhattan and kind of asks a question
maybe that's why he came here he really
wanted to see why you guys are me and
ring around in such useless roles why do
you guys are spinning your tails like
why you guys think you're actually
affecting change when you're not doing
anything at all and what would lead you
to believe that you're actually doing
anything when the evidence shows that
you're not like that's the cool thing
about this because at the end of the day
Vice whole stance is I failed I mean I
tried to unite the world under a
singular cause and it failed but at
least I did something you're doing
nothing and that's the funny thing here
because it comes down to the old adage
doing things changes things doing
nothing keeps things exactly as they are
and so what we do here is we pick up
with Johnny Thunder now the idea here is
that Johnny Thunder has basically been
trying to find the lantern of his friend
is really what he's saying you know if I
find my friends Lantern I'll find my
friend and I'll find the rest of my
friends and I won't be alone basically
he's trying to find the rest of the JSA
now looking at things that we've seen
from DC rebirth so far we know about a
few characters here and there and where
they're located at for example Jay
Garrick is stuck inside the Speed Force
because dr. Manhattan won't let him
leave but characters like talon scott
all these different members of the of
the JSA proper we don't really know
where they are and so with this in mind
we end up having like Johnny Thunder
being chased by like a handful of a
handful of criminals and like running
through sewer systems and so on and
going and cutting through corridors at
the same time
man thrown out of the actual vessel by
Adrian Veidt and Adrian's this kind of
like Bessel lucky man because all these
protests and everything it's all for
Batman they want him like they literally
want him to pay for all the things that
he's done and so this is like an awesome
segment because what happens here is
that as Johnny Thunders making his way
through these sewers he turns a corner
and there's the lantern of alan scott
and as soon as i saw that i was like
holy like holy how i can't blow it like
we have the green lantern of alan scott
like this is so cool
because i'm about you guys but i look at
stuff like this and it makes me
nostalgic for an era of comics that i
wasn't part of you know branded Johnny
Thunder can't do anything with the
lantern but we know where the lantern is
and if we know where the lantern is then
we can trace it back to to Alan Scott
and eventually figure out what's going
on with it and that's the big question
that we're trying that we're trying to
understand here because if what we were
told in DC Universe rebirth number one
is to be believed then what it basically
happened here is dr. Manhattan had
showed up on the scene right like you
had the flash Barry Allen who initiated
flashpoint which is where he screwed up
the whole universe he tried to set
things back things were supposed to go
back to normal but some were but you
know for some reason dr. Mann hadn't
intervened and so what seems to be going
on here with regards to the other
members of the JSA is that dr. Manhattan
basically wiped their their existence
from the minds of everyone and maybe
even like cost them their own memories
of who they are and so you know Alice
Scott has no idea who he is he's just
kind of floating around out there doing
whatever is it he's doing working some
job with no idea that he's the original
Green Lantern so it's kind of cool but
then from there you end up having like
Rorschach and Saturn girl who basically
rescue him and of course down a girl
kind of makes a comment look these guys
we're all gonna die of an overdose
anyway so the world won't miss them and
so picking up with with with marionette
it's awesome because one is up happening
here is that when they go through and
they start causing all this havoc and
they basically watch Batman crash down
onto the bat signal then they suddenly
get a response from someone off someone
had a panel who simply just addresses
them as YouTube they turn around and we
have the Joker and this is amazeballs
this is why I love I love Doomsday Clock
so much but I hate it at the same time
because Geoff Johns ends it on the best
cliffhangers and it's just like damn
like do these to meet the Joker The
Joker's finally here at the same time
Rorschach looks to to Johnny Thunder and
says explain what this is what is this
Lantern and how does this work give us
an idea of what in the world is going on
and so it's so cool like it's it's it's
really really awesome and it's one of
the cool things about this is we get
like all these cool elements is sort of
roll over into the DC universe as we
know it I mean it rolls into like all
these great concepts and kind of brings
them all together and unifies everything
in a way that we're that we're hoping
comes out of your really I guess will
really lead into like the finalized
version of the DC landscape post rebirth
okay so we are finally getting back in a
Doomsday Clock and that's that's a crazy
thing do say o'clock comes out like once
every two or three months now like it's
uh it's it's basically a quarterly
publication right I mean this is kind of
a weird thing you know if DC rebirth is
really going back to the roots of comics
it actually kind of makes sense that DC
would do something like this
I mean this is being done because of you
know just delays in the title but back
in the day like back when you had like
the all-star comics like it was all star
quarterly like you had quarterly comics
that were released by Marlowe I'm sorry
by DC that would usually feature like
team-ups different things like that it
was a cool concept and in reality I
wouldn't mind seeing DC bring back
quarterly you know quarterly
publications that are like big events or
something along those lines but doesn't
need to be like Marvel works like a big
crossover event every every you know
every quarter I mean that's the best a
little much but it does fit in with the
idea of fitting nicely with what DC is
trying to achieve here now really in the
the last bit of Doomsday Clock remember
this is really kind of Jeff John setting
the stage for the post Doomsday Clock
era of DC which is to say what comes
after Superman's conversation are really
probably even battle with dr. Manhattan
of course no idea how in the world
Superman's gonna win that fight what
this did is is in a lot of ways it
picked up on really focused on mine and
marionette that's really what a lot of
of Doomsday Clock had done but up to
this point we'd also seen like the
return of Johnny Thunder or at least we
seen his character featured we saw the
return of of the the lantern of Alan
Scott so like we know Alan Scott's out
there somewhere it's kind of like these
little bits and bobs these small little
tidbits at Jeff John throws in that it's
like the return of the JSA now in truth
again when it comes to mom and
marionette ah they're basically just you
know they're copies of what is a patch
and Julie I think it is but they're
basically plays on characters that
existed in Charlton comics back in the
day but with mom and marionette they're
essentially new creations and so we
didn't really know what their story was
we didn't really know where they came
from or the last thing we'd seen is they
found themselves rolled up in the Joker
and so of course when it comes to to the
character of marionette herself
initially this picks up with this whole
scenario of her father just at least
seemingly being ransacked in her
essentially watching it off now what
this does is it really like sets the
stage for the tone of the story and
really for the nature of them because
what it means is it starts things off by
essentially saying this girl comes from
a very rough past and that's one of the
important things because what you've
also got is the two of them having met
the Joker and that's the big difference
here that's really kind of how Jeff
John's juxtaposes the Joker with mime
and marionette and says they're not
actually the same thing because when we
first saw them when we first picked up
with Doomsday Clock and we looked at
mine the marionette is like okay so
they're basically Jeff John's version of
what would what Harley Quinn and the
Joker would be like but in reality
that's not the case that when it comes
to the Joker himself he's just an insane
man depending on what origin you're
reading either it's tragic or is just
kind of how things felt now the fact
that Joker has a Batman it's kind of
somebody to notice here of course we saw
that play out in the in Alaska in the
last video that we did in the last story
so it's not like it's it just kind of
came out of nowhere but it's not like
he's he's just like oh we got to take
him and torture him what we got to do
all these crazy things he's like yep I
got Batman business as usual like that's
kind of how it feels because what this
is Jeff Jones doing is saying yeah
Joker's got Batman and that's a big deal
but there's much bigger deals coming
down the line namely Superman and
document Hatton so it's it's like the
one thing everybody's excited for but
from here we basically end up running
into a handful of henchmen basically of
mr. fruits now when the Joker comes
across these guys we end up finding out
that Mr Freeze is kind of vanished now
we'll find out where he went to but
they're like Mr Freeze is kind of
vanished like we don't really know where
you went to we went off the grid he's
off the radar
and so the Joker's response is well then
join my crew now it's one of these
things where if the Joker comes across
your path and he extends you an
invitation to join his crew it's not
really an invitation you can turn down
now at this point we switch back to the
past of marionette you know with her her
father essentially you know running this
shop called maze glass and it's kind of
interesting because what what happened
there's another kid across the street
whose family runs another store
themselves now of course this guy is as
most of you guys have probably guessed
is essentially mine like he's the guy
that will grow up to become mine but
it's kind of cool because marionette and
like immediately takes a liking to but
the problem is that this kid doesn't
really talk he doesn't really say
anything and he's actually kind of a
standby like all these puppets and all
these things that are there so again
this is kind of jumping back and forth
they're sort of switching back between
the origin of mine and marionette and
jumping back to the current moment but
one thing to also keep in mind here is
that mime and marionette weren't really
crazy they're just kind of out doing
their own thing and they basically play
up again
that is in relation to their characters
of course marionette as we know took up
the mantle because she her father was uh
was a you know was a puppet guy and you
know mime doesn't really talk so we
don't like the roles they play reflect
the lives they've led but they've never
encountered anyone like the Joker before
because rumored mom and marionette are
basically displaced from the from the
watchman universe quote-unquote and so
they're used to more like grounded
people like people who were villains but
are really more of like fly-by-night
villains they're morally more you know
it's kind of goofy or ah they just sort
of do things you know like if a crazy
person decided to dress up as like a as
a gladiator decide they want to ride a
sort like that's the kind of villain
that they're used to they're not used to
someone like the Joker the Joker is so
chaotic the Joker is so unpredictable it
makes it it makes it crazy and when they
options give it like hey do you guys
want to join my thing to Joker's like no
no mom and Mary never like no no we're
not going to but at the same time
they're also pretty intense because they
basically escape the Joker's scheme is
by like poking out the eyes of one of
the of one of the henchmen with
marionette decapitating the other so
it's not like they're helpless right
it's not like oh wow this is a crazy
situation but I don't know how to deal
with this not at all the issue here is
that when the Joker really really comes
with a joker takes out one of his own
guys that's really what kind of baffles
mom and marionette to a degree and even
baffles the henchman of of mr. freeze
because for the most part is kind of be
expected for us as the reader but if
your mom and marionette is just kind of
like this is a little weird but the more
they stay together the more different
they are the more similarities they find
they have between the other but the fact
remains here jumping back to the past of
of marionette they're really sort of
coming together moment of marioneta and
mine comes in the fact that marionettes
basically being taunted by a handful of
bullies and so you know they they
literally like string her up and they
hold her in place and just start beating
the crap out of her when she starts to
fight back and so of course here comes
mine cracks the bottle over the head of
one of them and then just starts beating
him with a broken beer bottle now of
course as we know bullies don't get
second chances and so this literally
leads to marionette just like chasing
this girl down like when she flees for
her life you know if she chases her down
it starts bubbling the heck out of her
she tries to apologize and then in turn
my Mary and that's like do you have
another bottle so we can help this girl
finish with all of her living and so it
is I mean it's it's like it's pretty
intense but here's one of the other
things to bear in mind too even at a
young age they're moving towards a
direction where it's just the two of us
that's really kind of the the road
they're going in and so it's kind of
cool because what is up happening is neo
following the Joker we end up finding
out that
essentially happened the reason why mr.
Frese vanish is because all the villains
of DCF have essentially located in one
place or at least the most notable
villains so you have like Hector ham and
basically the earth-based villains
Hector ham and the penguin two-face leo
all these different guys but they're all
basically being led by the Riddler The
Riddler basically says like we're all
coming together to form our own secret
society of super villains or legion of
legion of doom or whatever it is that
you want to call it but it's basically
geoff johns way of saying like this old
formation of the villains banding
together you know against like this
superhero community is gonna return it's
gonna come back but notice there's kind
of a veritable who's who here like for
example you have dr. sivana now of
course we know Sivan is gonna be here
because of the fact that Shazam is
coming back but you've also got like you
know Captain cold you've got boomerang
here's something else to that I don't
believe has been introduced yet in the
mainline DC Comics you've got the judge
of Alice where you have the court of
owls and then you've got like the
monarchy of owls whatever in the world
is called now you've got the judge of
owls which is basically though the one
person who's in charge of like all the
owls of the Batman mythos that exists
out there in in the world so it's kind
of cool to see that expanded but then
you also see them hitting at typhoon now
typhoons a character has been around for
a long long time so he's not really like
a rework of dr. Manhattan but here's a
funny thing he could be and the reason
why I say that is I mean the clueless
the clearest similarity between the two
is the color of their skin the fact that
they're both blue but in truth David
Drake made his debut back in flash
number 294 way back in the day so again
he's been around for a very very very
long time
his powers just weather manipulation
he's mostly been a flash villain and his
powers been confined in a smaller scale
he's never really been like a major
player but in reality it wouldn't be
that hard for dr. Manhattan to just like
take out the original typhoon dress up a
sly foon and then go into the main DC
Universe the question is why like why
would dr. Manhattan do that which is why
it's really not a believable theory but
it is kind of a funny idea to sort of
toy around with but then from here we
basically switch back again to the
origin of marionette and this is when we
end up finding out that what had
basically been happening at this time
when she was a little kid is that her
father was basically being shaken down
by the cops that the cops were crooked
you know they were they were coming in
and they were saying like you owe us a
debt basically like you owe us a try the
source of course they also end up
dropping the news that this young kid
Marco that Marcos bit his mom died she
essentially fell down a fire escape and
that was really the end of her but again
it's it's another one of these things
were it's just like they they live a
pretty rough life there's a lot of
really really shady things going on here
not only that kind of jumping back to
the to the current moment we end up
finding out this is not the first time
the Joker's shown up with a Batman
trying to get himself into this team
which is so Joker it's exactly what
Joker would do like from what we're
being told previously the Joker hitch
shown up with like a prison guard from
Arkham Asylum dressed him as the Batman
and said I've captured the Batman see
you guys can I join your team now it's
kind of a funny little thing now of
course this leads to a bit of a skirmish
between like typhoon and and the rest of
the villains because it's just kind of
like hey look your typhoon like you
really don't need to be here man like
you're pretty small-time and then of
course in the middle of all this typhoon
gets shot in the face and this is when
things really pop off because we end up
fighting out the person who shot typhoon
in the face is the comedian and dude
okay so this is this is when things get
so awesome because then it's literally a
bloodbath
he's just firing on everyone like all
these different villains he's taking
every last one in the mouth now mime
starts making his way over to try to
take out comedian and marionette
immediately calls him back but of course
he doesn't necessarily respond and set
like gigantic gets in the way of you
know comedian and then of course he kind
of has to jam out of the way of her
onslaught but from there like it's
literally taking potshots I mean it's
just it's like it's like the punisher
rolled into like the hideout of like all
the Marvel villains and just starts
shooting everybody to pieces that's what
the comedian's doing right now like he
literally shows up in this place and
just starts taking all of them out but
like most people here just kind of react
the way you would expect like they just
kind of scatter but like for most people
they don't really know what's going on
they're responsive a marionette is we
have to get out of here this is the
comedian he will kill assault but notice
this where we as the reader would look
at this and we would think that
initially the Joker has more in common
with mom and marionette than anybody
else the Joker actually has more in
common with the comedian that sure the
comedian is a vigilante but it's like
mime and marionette and the comedian
both represent different sides of the
Joker but it's basically like it's him
just as a comedian like hey look I'm
gonna kill you all so like you can run
if you want to but I will find you I'll
track you down and then I'll then I'll
take you out so it's one of these crazy
things because it's like it's like this
is exactly how we would expect the
comedian's arrival to unfold in the this
whole landscape of DC comics and so
again switching back to this last you
know this this next little tidbit of
marionettes origin the cops show up
again but the issue is that the father
basically stands up and says I can't let
you guys shake me down anymore
especially not in front of my daughter
because what she's gonna do is she's
gonna grow up believing
give people whatever they want and life
will be easier which is a terrible way
to live the issue it is the response to
this is they grab they grab marionette
they bring around and they're like look
you can
us what we want or we will kill your
daughter what we in defining out is that
the this guy you know that the father is
essentially is kind of like he's he's
got a an actual financial tithe he has
to pay money that has to be given which
is currently hidden inside the night owl
adult which of course you know they
crack it open they take the money out
and that's that you know they end up
leaving that's where he stores you know
the extra cash and so what ends up
happening here is it's this situation
where you know she goes and after this
whole scenario she basically goes and
ends up hanging out with Marcos you know
it starts to you know poking around
asking questions can you really not talk
like what more the ones going on she
returns back to the shop you know after
you know the next day or so only to find
that her father hung himself and this is
when things get really really crazy
because now it's just her she's alone
there's no one else there this is all
that's left because her father leaves a
note behind that says look you know then
they would have never stopped coming
it's one of these things if you give an
inch you give a mile you given to them
the first time and they'll keep coming
back the only way to make them stop is
to get rid of them but in this instance
I'm leaving you behind because now you
can go out and you can make your own you
make your own life and so in response to
this where he says empty the till take
the money and leave when the cops show
up to collect their tithe she stabs one
of them in the neck now where the other
one starts to panic this is when like
mine runs in bites the other one he
offers himself as a distraction of sorts
and then like literally marionette comes
running in with basically with a with a
marionette wire and strangles the guy to
death so like right off the bat like
it's basically just the two of us worthy
like we're the only two in the world
that we can count on this is it it's
essentially like the fallout from this
whole situation than with from their
initial origin this sort of comes home
to roost when they have this
conversation because when they get back
to their safe house she's like you you
can't leave me like that like if I have
if I don't have you I don't have anybody
else like this is it because we end up
finding out that following this they
made their way on the street the best
way they could they literally did what
they had to do in order to make ends
meet so it's it's one of these things
worse like like look it's just us like
we have to stick together we're the only
real connection the two of us have and
we have to go find our baby together so
it's a pretty important moment and it
really gives a lot of depth to the
character now from there the comedian
comes like tracked him down the comedian
lives up to his word he's like I will
find you
literally track them down and says you
guys can come with me and you guys can
show me where Ozymandias is or I can
kill one of you and make the other show
me of course in the midst of all this
the comedian's essentially knocked out
from behind and we end up finding the
Joker was the one who did it and so of
course the Joker steals the comedian's
button and it's just kind of like well
I'm curious about this dr. Manhattan
look what's the deal with this dr.
Manhattan like we should go find dr.
Manhattan and this is awesome because
what it means is the Joker will meet dr.
Manhattan okay so we are picking up with
Doomsday Clock number seven and this is
actually kind of an interesting scenario
here because what Geoff Johns does in
this story is he messes with us
he really kind of toys us a little bit
and it's actually pretty cool it's kind
of cool to see him CMS with things a bit
so what this does is this picks up with
the Green Lantern of Allen Scott now for
those of you guys who don't know of
course this is really kind of where we
left off in the last Doomsday Clock
story and Geoff Johns picking up with
this actually offers some pretty
intriguing things so the first thing I
want to do here is I want to talk about
something called the Justice Society of
America back in the 1940s when you had
like Gardner Fox and those guys who were
really kind of creating you know DC
characters and teams the Justice Society
of America was the first team that DC
had they were the predecessors to the
Justice League it's one of the big
misconceptions that a lot of non comic
book readers have is that the Justice
League was the first big team not at all
the JSA were really like small-time
characters you had like you know the the
original flash Jay Garrick the original
Green Lantern Alan Scott Hawkman
different people like that I think the
spectre was part of it at one point
maybe was dr. fate and then you got into
1960 with Justice League which gave us
kind of like the second iteration of the
JSA but with a more popular team now
because of the fact that the original
JSA for the 1940s in real time the
original JSA existed on earth too which
was a different universe when DC got rid
of the multiverse and what they did is
they came back and they said actually
the JSA were world war two superheroes
and so by the time Batman and Superman
and Wonder Woman and Aquaman by the time
they'd risen to prominence and became
superheroes in the modern era the JSA
had basically retired now DC tried to
come back and change that a little bit
but Geoff Johns is sort of bringing that
back in and what he's doing here is he's
really kind of does it by way of dr.
Manhattan talking to us and it's kind of
a big deal with the original Green
Lantern of Allen Scott it wasn't
actually a Green Lantern per se I mean
it was insofar as it was a red I'm sorry
a green meteor the crash into Earth and
it was kind of a lamp that was turned
into a lantern but it wasn't until after
a really you know much later on in DC
Comics that they actually rolled Alan
Scott over into quote-unquote the Green
Lantern Corps originally his Green
Lantern ring was totally separate from
all the other Green Lantern's that
existed out there and so with regards to
this you got you know Jeff John's kind
of runs through the origin which is
pretty straight forward but he says
small things now here's a
anything about this is that dr.
Manhattan says this in a wage where it
doesn't happen in a linear fashion and
that's one thing to keep in mind right
like he doesn't say like in in nineteen
forty this happened and in nineteen
fifty this happened and in nineteen
sixty that happened he says like in
nineteen forty this happened and then in
nineteen sixty this happened and then in
nineteen fifty that happened dr.
Manhattan does not see time linearly
dr. Manhattan sees everything all at
once he sees the whole span of time
happening all at one time the difference
here is that he can't travel back and
forth through time he can only see it
and so because of this it's really
interesting here because one of the
things he says is that we're in the
originally when Alan Scott was a
railroad engineer and had come across
the Green Lantern they the actual
answered itself what dr. Manhattan did
is he moved it so that Alan Scott never
came across it and that's kind of a big
deal because what this means is that
because dr. Manhattan cannot travel a
travel through time but because dr.
Manhattan affected the ability for Alan
Scott to become the Green Lantern it
means dr. Manhattan had to have been
there in that moment when that happened
and so it's kind of interesting here
because this this seems to go and seems
to really indicate the dr. Manhattan was
responsible for the creation of the DC
Universe but what geoff johns is gonna
do here in a little bit is kind of say
actually he's not and that's that's kind
of the funny thing about this and so
what we end up doing here is picking up
with like saturn girl and with Johnny
Thunder and with Rorschach and and with
Ozymandias again they're all basically
trying to track down dr. Manhattan
that's the real big thing that they're
looking for here and it's kind of an
interesting scenario because what we've
also been seeing kind of going on in the
background is this scenario worse like
the Superman conspiracy right they're
like superheroes are engineered by the
federal government which is why so many
superheroes operate inside the United
States because it's kind of a government
mandated initiative and and so on and so
forth now the other thing about this is
that in the original Watchmen comics
what you had was a character called
Bubastis that was created by created by
Ozymandias it was just kind of like his
attempt to create life more or less but
following the death of that original
Bubastis and his attempt to like destroy
dr. Manhattan what ended up happening is
that awesome Andy has created a new
version but instead of this just being
being Bubastis what it is it's really
like a homing beacon it's a device that
would allow him to essentially track
down dr. Manhattan and so like like a
radar or like a you know a radar that
might be prouder and louder or at a
faster frequency as an object gets
closer to it what this version of
Bubastis does is it kind of lights up a
little bit more now the other part of
this is it also picks up with a comedian
remember that also happened as well and
it's kind of cool to see geoff johns do
this where
brings in the comedian the comedian
assaults like a large majority of the
various villains out of Gotham and then
when like Rorschach and everybody flees
you kind of see what comedian was doing
in the background by way of like the
news or something along those lines and
so switching directly over to comedian
himself again he's been taken by the
Joker and it's kind of cool to see this
because at the outset you would think
the comedian would have a lot in common
with the Joker - insanity in the sense
of the comedian's very Punisher like in
terms of how he functions or I guess
maybe if the Punisher is more like the
comedian in terms of how he functions
but the fact remains the Joker is
absolutely insane and the comedian picks
up on that insanity almost immediately
and it's just like let me out of here
getting you let me out of here let me go
back and do my thing you know comedians
desire you know Eddie Eddie Blake's
desire just kind of get out of there is
first and foremost but he doesn't
function like a crazy person here and
remember that's the nature of the
comedian the comedian doesn't have the
name because he's a spinoff of the Joker
he has the name because in his mind but
he's not really a tried and true
nihilist he just kind of looks at the
nature of humanity and says the only
thing you can do is laugh about it and
so there are some similarities between
himself and the Joker in that regard he
just lacks the kind of extreme insanity
narcissism and borderline multiple
personality disorder that the Joker has
and so it's kind of interesting but in
the middle of all this they're suddenly
met by the arrival of Batman who's
basically been tracking the comedian now
of course this leads to Batman basically
taking them out only for mime to
basically fire off you know one of his
invisible guns and seemingly take Batman
by surprise now again it doesn't really
kill him but it is kind of cool to see
Batman facing off against you know these
these characters monta marionette
characters that he's never seen before
but still when they when they finally
secure the Green Lantern of Allen Scott
what ends up happening is that
Ozymandias basically begins to bring the
two together and it's one of these
things were like they're all kind of
like in a mad dash to the same location
because the cat's leading them to a
place and then you have Ozymandias
following the cat and of course what we
end up finding out here is that where
the Joker's going insane and Batman's
facing them all the cat has been leading
Ozymandias to the comedian and the
reason why is because the cat picks up
on these sort of residues more or less
that better that are there that are left
by dr. Manhattan and so what geoff johns
kind of does is in a roundabout way he
indicates that in some former fashion
dr. Mann had brought Eddie Blake back
that either he brought him back to life
or something along those lines we're not
entirely sure when you end up having
like Ozymandias sort of bringing the cat
and then bringing the the lantern
together and all those different things
what is up happening is you suddenly
have you know essentially dr. Manhattan
manifests himself and it's kind of crazy
because the way that Jeff Jones does is
is it almost seemed for an instant that
like dr. Manhattan was pretending to be
the comedian but then of course when
Manhattan's there you have the comedian
sitting in a chair so of course that
wasn't really the case but it's kind of
crazy because man had you know the the
response of Ozymandias as we need to
talk now at the outset Batman's
responses I know who you are and it had
been kind of cool to see a little more
of an interaction between the two of
them but again Jeff Jones is a slow
build he's a slow burn when it comes to
writing and so you're never really gonna
see like a four-issue arc where just
things just pop off if given the
opportunity Jeff John seems to always
deviate towards telling a longer story
that's more thought-out that has a lot
more dialogue and a lot more plot
building to it which is one of the
things that makes him an excellent
writer you know one of the best comic
book writers to ever live and so dr.
Manhattan grabs them all and just kind
of whisks them away you know out to what
seems like the middle of nowhere and the
responses let's talk let's see what it
is that you have to say and we're
awesome and 'ya says look you know the
the actual Watchmen world is in shambles
you have to come back and fix things
dr. Manhattan response is no I'm not
going to and this is where Jeff John's
kind of says that Manhattan didn't
really create the DC universe or at
least it seems to be that case when he
says I left that world for a reason and
I came to this world and so it you know
the the the statement really seems to
indicate dr. Manhattan came to the DC
universe after the DC universe had
already come into existence now we don't
know how early he got here dr. Manhattan
kind of sees time and a nonlinear way
and so where we would look at it from
the perspective of well dr. Mann dr.
Manhattan got here like 60 years ago
from his perspective he was just here
and so the way he talks here that's
really kind of the tools and the clues
that geoff johns leaves to us to
determine whether or not manhattan
created everything and saying things
like i was at this point in time i saw
these things take place it all kind of
seems as though dr. Manhattan got here
before superheroes came into existence
but after the a after the formation of
the DC Universe it was kind of a funny
thing because when he starts talking to
marionette when the statements made by
chose to spare you not because I thought
you were a great person who you deserved
it but because you were pregnant and I
saw what your child would go on to do we
know that from her origin story in the
earlier videos and so when the question
is asked well you know what's my child
gonna do
Manhattan responds by saying well which
one and then all that's right you know
you don't see time the same way I do
you're pregnant right now that was kind
of interesting the way that John's
writes the character Manhattan he does a
great job doing it but it's very very
difficult for writers to mirror the
style of another
righter identical and when you look at
the old alan moore writing of the
Watchmen the way he wrote manhattan was
very disconnected but when you look at
manhattan here there's a hint of anger
it seems like he's kind of irritated or
or angry with people the other half of
this is that you end up having like
Rorschach who's talking about you know
Ozymandias and saying Ozymandias has
cancer and manhattan says no he doesn't
you know and that's when Ozymandias
drops the drops his big truth bomb and
says no i never had cancer when he's
talking to Reggie the new Rorschach he
says no I never had cancer I said that
because I needed you and this is really
really really important at the outset it
just kind of seems like man what a dick
move but this is insanely important
because what this means is that it means
Ozymandias is just as manipulative as he
ever was that he saw the opportunity to
use Reggie to use Rorschach for his own
ends and took it and so it means that
like in in reality Ozymandias hasn't
changed at all he's the same person that
we saw in the old Watchmen comics when
he thought he was saving the world and
and set this monster loose in the city
of New York and he's still that same
person and dr. Manhattan sees that and
says you're the same person you ever
worked you know you are coming here
asking me to save a world that you
couldn't save why would I do that
it's a laboring beast gasping for breath
let that world die and so when you end
up having Reggie kind of freaking out on
on Ozymandias it's interesting because
what Ozymandias says is it's like you
live up to your namesake that you are
really a Rorschach painting you are a
reflection of what you wish to see and
what he says is what you've wanted to
see was that your father in Rorschach
we're friends what you wanted to see was
that your father was championing
Rorschach's caused and that you were
gonna pick this up as well the reality
of the situation is that war Shaq
destroyed everything your father stood
for he destroyed your father's desire to
live a beautiful life he left him as a
fractured broken man you didn't see that
because you didn't want to see that and
it's kind of a crazy scenario because
when you think about that it's it's kind
of mind-boggling they're like Ozymandias
makes these incredible these incredible
observations but then you have Manhattan
who sort of goes back to the old into
the watchman's stories you know where
he's like you know this time is is like
a time is coming when I can't see past
what happens next I can't see the future
beyond this particular point in time and
he doesn't really tell us right off the
bat why that is it's just for some
reason he can't see what's coming later
on down the line
and so it seems as though some bigger
threat either from Manhattan or that
will work through Manhattan kind of
seems to be an indication here and it's
kind of crazy you know when he starts
musing about these things that he's seen
how he's for how he perceives time how
all this stuff works it really sort of
hits home again so when you end up
having you know him
basically walking away and just saying
I'm done and then just leaving and then
sending everybody back things just kind
of go awry after that people sort of
regained their bearings and then
everything just pops off you have Batman
and Joker who were dealing with
Rorschach beating the crap out of Oz
manious you've got mana marionette who
take their leave you got all kinds of
crazy stuff happening here
and so the Joker of course being as it
being as insane as he ever was when you
end up getting out there to to Johnny
Thunder when you get up end up getting
out there to Saturn girl when I was a
man dia shows back up he's been beat to
pieces and so it's just like what in the
world is going on but he starts hiding
his thoughts from Saturn girl so she
can't read his mind just different
things like that and of course he turns
against her and says I have a plan I'm
going to fix everything when he throws
out Johnny Thunder when he throws out
Saturn girl he's like I'm gonna fix
everything I'm gonna solve the problem
of everything and it's kind of crazy
because following this we pick back up
again with dr. Manhattan and what he
says that it what he says is that this
thing that happens in a one-month period
basically it's the arrival of Superman
and for some reason Superman is
outrageously pissed and of course this
comes by way of Reggie sending off
information to Lois Lane so that's how
we end up getting Superman into the mix
but the idea is that Superman for some
reason gets it's so astronomically
pissed off that he shows up here he
basically goes to punch dr. Manhattan
and then everything goes black and what
Manhattan can't figure out here and this
is what's so intriguing
what Manhattan cannot figure out here is
if everything goes black because
Superman destroys him with a single
punch or if everything goes black
because he destroys Superman and
everything else and so Jeff Jones leaves
it so ambiguous because if I'm if I'm a
betting man I would bet all the money in
my pockets to all the money in your
pockets which is zero for me I don't
know about you most likely what's going
to happen is if Superman fought dr.
Manhattan Superman probably wouldn't win
you're talking about a guy who can
control the atomic structure of matter
against a guy who can just punch really
hard and so when you have those things
kind of thrown together it's really kind
of an obvious choice on who's gonna win
but we don't know what state Superman
will be in we don't know if you'll have
automated powers we don't know if Geoff
Johns is gonna amp him up to a higher
level than we've ever seen him before
it'll if it'll be one of those things
where Geoff Johns has Superman pull out
all the mental blocks so he's running on
100% power and it's just astronomically
insane in terms of what he can do we
don't really know okay so getting into
Doomsday Clock kana this is this is kind
of a slow bill but it is really starting
to pick up we've got about four more
issues and at the end of this is like
something really really big happens
which is kind of cool but this initially
picked up with Lois Lane and Clark in
inside the
now the way the Jeff John start this the
source is really kind of like Lois Lane
getting yelled out you know for a story
and nothing really crazy nothing bonkers
from what we would normally expect to
see with regards to what goes on in the
Daily Planet between Lois Lane Perry
White Clark Kent you know the various
reporters but in the middle of all this
we end up finding out the firestorm
Ronnie Raymond is in Russia fighting his
arch-nemesis hos are now the reason why
this matters is because this ties in to
the Superman theory of those guys who
were who are kind of jumping into this
in Doomsday Clock one of the things that
Jeff Charles is established is that
there's this theory that's circulating
around the world very very fast that
various metahumans are basically
american-made that most metahumans 90%
of them in fact exist inside the United
States and so the argument is the United
States government is creating metahumans
now for the most part this isn't really
the case
I mean various characters like killer
frost or a byproduct of experiments gone
wrong but for the most part most
metahumans don't seem to be like part of
a government conspiracy or anything like
that it just happens to be them in some
form of fashion they're tied in to some
government project or something like
that but we know Superman is from a
different planet we know that that
people like Ronnie Raymond or the result
of an experiment gone wrong we know that
that that these characters are not tied
into the Superman theory and Ronnie
Raymond has publicly denounced this time
and time again but really kind of like
leads the battle directly against Russia
and the reason why is because what the
Russian government's been doing is
implementing metahuman laws and what
this basically means is that babies and
various people are being tested for a
metahuman gene and if they test positive
they're being taken into custody and no
real questions are being asked at the
other half of this is that Russia has
been drumming up anti metahuman hysteria
really like feeding on the fear of its
own people and so the result of this is
that the Russian people are very much
against metahumans so when Ronnie
Raymond shows up they immediately turn
against him and the result is that when
he's essentially knocked down by pose
art he's surrounded by all these various
you know people protestors so on and so
forth and the results that he kind of
lashes out and turns them all to glass
now for the character of Ronnie this can
be brought about by a couple different
explanations two main explanations the
first is that is a byproduct of his
ability to transmute matter which is the
most likely explanation here the other
part of this could just be extreme heat
that is literally he let off such an
astronomical amount of heat that these
folks all turned to glass now in truth
you're talking about something that
you're also going to be equivalent to a
nuclear explosion so the fact that there
are still like building standing and
the entire place is not totally
incinerated is an indication that of
course it's just the transmutation of
matter but what this does is to everyone
watching it makes it look like Ronnie
Raymond killed all these people
they're firestorm in American superhero
flew to Russia and then killed all these
various people it gives the Russian
arguments credence is what it does so of
course this leads to Ronnie Raymond flee
now what we end up having a Superman
who's watching the entire thing unfold
who leaves a Daily Planet and travels to
conduct and this is kind of a cool a
cool moment here now for the character
of Black Adam because what I'm about to
say next I want to go ahead and kind of
you know kind of instill this in you
guys black out has been around since
1945 he's been around for a very very
long time the black Adam and magneto are
very very similar in this regard the
reason why I set why state when Black
Adam would show up is because somebody
would be half listening and just be like
he's nothing like magneto magneto came
way after black out of here what are you
talking about this of course he did I
know he did
but the fact remains with Black Adam and
magneto they're very very similar in
this regard when it comes to when it
comes to Black Adam while he is
contentedly considered a villain it's
really only one of these things where
like he'll fight against you if there's
a legitimate threat to conduct that's
where his loyalties lie do not attack
him he will not attack you not only that
what what Black Adam had basically done
was open the doors of conduct to those
individuals who were looking to find an
escape from general society because with
a Superman theory being so popular what
this means is that a lot of people are
siding against it like a lot of people
are citing against metahumans and with
them siding against metahumans it's
given metahumans reason to fear for
their lives and so finding some place to
flee conduct was opened up as a safe
refuge of source now here's the other
important thing to Lois Lane had
basically received this package you know
they kind of came out of nowhere with a
USB Drive and when she plugged it in
this USB Drive contains information
about the Justice Society of America and
Lois Lane has no idea who that is
now we know this because with what's
going on what we've seen so far
dr. Manhattan to change things right
like dr. Manhattan and move the lantern
out of the way so Alan Scott never
became the Green Lantern in fact died
before that could happen we know things
like like Johnny Thunder was you know
like he was a hero at one point he's
basically largely been forgotten the
Justice Society of America has long
since been forgotten by people and is
basically Geoff Johns and DC's way of
explaining why we haven't
seen them since a new 52 I mean we got
earth too but that's the different
that's a whole different version of
Heroes this is a different version of
Jay Garrick is a different version of
Superman the whole nine yards the JSA as
we know them which is to say the team
that people remember from before the new
52 back during the 90s during the 80s
and way before the 80s is so on and so
forth that teams been gone for a long
time and so while they are making their
return what this does is it establishes
the JSA did exist which means the
question becomes if they existed and
there's there's actual documented
evidence of their existence then why
doesn't anyone remember that why don't
people like Hawkman remember being part
of the JSA because Hawkman still a lot
so why don't why don't they remember why
does it remember being part of the JSA
why are those memories gone now we can
largely assume that feeds into like the
10 years lost from everyone but unless
the JSA only existed during those 10
years did we have to believe they just
said beforehand which means that they've
been wiped away from the minds of
everyone something that seemingly only
dr. Manhattan would really be able to
pull off and so again it's really kind
of thickening the plot basically
bringing back a lot of these older
characters establishing who they are
what they're about but also saying like
they were here once so where are they
now and so again we don't care just like
Jay Garrick is stuck inside the Speed
Force we know that like Alan Scott
doesn't exist we know different things
like that but like for the other members
who were out there the other characters
you know who are who are part of this
whole thing you know where are they our
man and and so on and so forth you know
so Oh what is up going on here if
Superman goes to locate Ronnie Raymond
only to find out that his powers are
basically running amuck to a degree
they're really kind of going a little
bit bonkers and where Superman's able to
kind of talk Ronnie Raymond down and
have him work alongside professor Stein
and basically transmit this kid back to
his normal human form after having been
turned to glass this kind of feeds into
the nature of Superman's character now
this is very very important because when
it comes to Superman and DC Comics he's
not so much a father figure for the
various superheroes so much as he is
kind of like the penultimate hero right
like the leader of it all the kind of
the guy who kind of inspired everybody
else to become a hero as one of the
cures they kind of look up to but this
is Geoff Johns establishing the nature
of Superman kind of reminding us where
Superman's about because this would
probably become important later on we
end up inevitably having the fight
between Superman and dr. Manhattan and
so it's kind of a cool little thing here
because when this kid gets changed back
what it does is it sets in motion the
idea that Ronnie Raymond can set
everybody else back to normal back in
Russia and so where he ends up
travelling back there of course Superman
arrives first and this is a very
important thing because when Superman
shows up here our initial inclination
might be
well you got Vladimir Putin who's
existing over the current guy in in in
Russia you know when in the show and and
then it's like okay Superman shows up
well clear they're gonna go in to attack
him no they're not and that's a very
important thing because Superman is a
hero who's beyond reproach
you know his stance where he resides
that's that is beyond contestation
everyone knows Superman is a protector
of earth he's a savior of Earth no one
questions his loyalty no one questions
his role he is definitively a good guy
and when he shows up here and the other
members of the superhero community in
Russia intend to attack Superman
Vladimir Putin steps in and says
absolutely not
Superman's a good guy Superman is
definitively a good guy but with
Superman showing up what he basically
does is say look the whole incident was
Robert Ronnie Raymond with firestorm
this is an accident it's one that can be
undone and when he makes this statement
it is okay well then let's see what the
guy has to say now the funny thing about
this is that Batman's watching the whole
event unfolding Batman as he's talking
to Superman his response is do not pick
Assad do not make a definitive
declaration and that's the important
thing to bear in mind here this whole
thing is called the Superman theory for
a reason that it all hinges on the idea
that it all started with Superman right
like Superman was the first hero first
superhero to operate out of you know
beta seemingly operate out of earth or
at least the most popular to operate out
of out of the United States and so the
result is that it all kind of centers
around him for him to make a declarative
statement does Superman theory is false
the Superman theory is wrong the
demonization of metahumans is wrong is
to pick Assad is to basically say anyone
who is in favor of the Superman theory
is incorrect the problem is they don't
have enough information here and that's
why Batman really takes his stance and
says do not pick a side because you
could be wrong and if you're wrong
you're gonna have egg on your face and
if you're wrong people are gonna look
you they're gonna point the finger as
they see it even Superman doesn't really
know what's going on but he's he's
clueless like the government's just that
secretive this that dark and
manipulative but Batman keeps harping on
him do not pick a side do not pick a
side do not pick a side Ronnie Raymond
shows up and says look I can fix
everyone I can set everything back to
normal
one of the soldiers pulls the trigger
fires a shot and Ronnie you know you
know how Superman kind of jumps in the
way protects him but Ronnie Raymond is
attacked by pose art and then in the
middle of it it really all seems to pop
off and that's why this whole thing has
one of the reasons why Batman said do
not pick a side because this will and
this will inevitably lead to a conflict
and if it does then it will be spun news
companies exist to sell themselves facts
be damned
they
just to sell themselves by any means
necessary and they'll suspend the story
however they have to in order to sell
themselves and so that's why this this
whole thing is a huge crapshoot because
the way this looks is Ronnie Raymond
basically killed a whole bunch of people
by turning him into glass Superman shows
up and says not only is right this can
this be reversed is it you know are you
guys wrong for demonizing Ronnie Raymond
the Superman Theory's false Ronnie
Raymond shows up all hell breaks loose
Superman takes sides against the
Russians it looks like the United States
government is acting against the Russian
government it looks like metahumans are
trying to destroy people who disagree
with him that's how it appears and in
this instance Ronnie Raymond begins to
basically start snapping Randy because
it's kind of loses mind began basically
powering up letting off this energy and
what is up having his Batman charms in
as a Superman you have to stop energy
levels are spiking
Superman's idea is that Ronnie Raymond
is powering up and Ronnie Marion is
about to destroy everything and the
response of Batman is it's not Ronnie
Raymond and that's what we'll remember
life and everything's gone seemingly dr.
Manhattan has stepped in now we don't
know what role document Hatton's taking
you all we know is that at this moment
dr. Manhattan has chosen to make his
move and we have to wait until February
to find out which sucks let me tell
y'all read a story that was so good you
want to punch a hole in the wall that's
exactly what this is
do if God will write in comic books
right now is what it will look like
right now okay so this story picks up in
the year 3000 and 19 and dr. manhattan's
just like okay so basically like the
earth is gonna be threatened and like a
guy you know tries to protect it and
basically dies of the process but the
crazy thing is like energy of this guy
lets off basically like Suns arene
careening back through time right and
then dr. Manhattan's going through and
he's like okay so like it's basically
like the the cascading effects right
like he's like okay this guy exists
because of the fact that Alan Scott
exists right but like I move the lantern
out of the way Alan Scott never became
the original Green Lantern which meant
that Alan Scott never founded the
original JSA which made like this Legion
of super-heroes never existed like is
literally just kind of analyzing the
effects of his own actions but remember
because a reason is going on dr.
Manhattan cannot see the end of all
things and he doesn't know if that's
because of the fact that he gets killed
by Superman or dr. Manhattan destroys
everything in reality so it's kind of
the coolest thing and so remember this
comes after firestorm had basic
like let off this massive explosion in
Russia which it was kind of tricked into
more or less and then in turn like the
world kind of turning against
superheroes more so than they already
were because those guys who were just
kind of catching up with those you guys
haven't read this
the Superman conspiracy is the on
running theme and Doomsday Clock the
idea that like there's this conspiracy
running around dead like all superheroes
or almost all superheroes were created
by America by the American government
and so with the explosion that happened
in Russia and all the other superheroes
basically kind of banding together what
we end up finding out here is that like
everyone has come together and when I
say everyone I mean like everyone like
the Justice League Odyssey team the
Justice League of America like all the
magic wielders all the super all the
members of the Superman family like
everyone is here and everybody's trying
to figure out what the heck is going on
and so it's kind of it's it's it's
amazing here because while all that
happens like you literally have like dr.
Manhattan who's just kind of musing to
himself he knows exactly what's gonna
take place but he's just kind of musing
to himself with like everything that's
going on with regards to like earth and
the superheroes and so on and so forth
so detached and not really concerned
about anything that's going on it's just
kind of there like I wonder what'll
happen next and really just kind of
concerned about like why he can't see
the future and it's kind of nuts because
like while all that goes on of course
Superman's recovering Batman recovering
they were both in like the immediate
vicinity of the explosion but then like
Lois Lane goes running to his side right
and like this really was kind of going
on is like all these themes are
effectively coming to a head but that
you've got the President of the United
States being addressed by like his
cabinet basically being told because the
explosion in Russia by firestorm fire
storms of metahuman the Superman II
conspiracy is already running strong
people already distrust superhumans you
have to do the only thing you can do if
you want to keep the White House they're
basically kind of asking him do you want
to be political or do you want to be
moral you can't be both and so the
president chooses or at least it seems
like he chooses to be political their
argument the argument of this cabinet is
you have to stand against metahumans
because that's what the general public
wants and at the end of the day you're a
servant of the people you have to do
what the people want you to do that
people want you to basically enact or at
least present legislation to Congress
that forces metahumans to reveal their
identities that basically removes the
ability for people to have mass it's
Watchmen all over again
and it's so cool here because then in
turn you basically have like Bruce Wayne
waking up inside Wayne Manor and you
know force like dread you know dressing
Alfred and so on and so forth all these
things are kind of happening at like a
really really fast clip and
one of the things people tend to forget
and somebody actually made a comment
about this on Twitter which is true that
one of the things people tend to forget
about the Watchmen is that it was it was
a slow build right like it was like the
slowest story ever until you get to the
second act and then things pop off but
basically what Batman essentially says
here like address like talking to Alfred
is like what's going on because the
humanity has taken all the all the
various superheroes who are essentially
like traveling out to Mars because
that's basically what's happening like
what Batman explains here is that like
after the whole event with firestorm did
like the source of energy that seemed to
basically cause firestorm to explode or
at least was deduced to believe to cause
fire storm to explode is coming from
Mars and that's where all the
superheroes are going they're all going
to confront dr. Manhattan and so with
Batman and Superman being the only two
left behind on earth alongside Wonder
Woman and I guess Green Arrow is that
what's what's basically going on is he's
like look I don't know if that energy
signature coming from Mars is the one
that actually caused all this I don't
know if that's what's really going on
there is a massive energy signature out
there and it does warrant being
investigated but like I think the
Justice League is getting played and
it's kind of crazy because that it that
in turn basically leaves the entire
earth vacated it leaves the entire earth
empty and so in in response to this like
Batman's like we need to send a message
off to them so it's kind of cool to see
this because when this happens we kind
of transition over to like everybody but
Batman Superman and like Wonder Woman
but like when they arrive on Mars it's
all the Green Lantern's it's it's the
whole nine yard is the whole kit and
caboodle and this is awesome thing
because while that happens you've got
Lois Lane standing over like the
hospitalized body of Superman in the
Hall of Justice and it's just this voice
that comes out of nowhere that says
hello Lois and it's Lex Luthor and it's
like okay so like Lex Luthor's making a
move now that was my thought my thought
was like okay so Lex Luthor is basically
gonna like kill Superman now now he's in
a super weakened state and Lois Lois
Lane's like you don't have a chance
you're not pulling this off it's crazy I
mean like Ronnie Raymond firestorm is
still alive they're in separate bodies
they kind of have to merge in order to
pull off whatever it is that they want
to pull off but still like Ronnie
Raymond kind of a CG Martin Stein and
say look like we have to reform his
firestorm we're almost like a reality
where were we can Rima T realize matters
like there's almost no limit to our
power whatsoever like we have to
basically work together here the Green
Lantern's create like this giant field
around Mars like all these steps are
being taken by all these different these
different individuals here to like
safeguard themselves is this huge
buildup everybody's preparing for like a
massive battle against like this one guy
but the
first one to speak up and talk is John
Jones well we're all like hey who are
you and what are you doing why you here
like my hens can like I've got stuff to
do but as basically kind of his response
is like hey man like you know look guys
like it's cool you're here but like I've
got bigger fish to fry besides you and
that's that's what's that's what's so
interesting about that is how like
dismissive dr. Manhattan is of like Dean
of the veritable who's who because
everyone is here everyone but the
villains are here like every single
superhero on earth is here and like dr.
Manhattan is just dismissive and we find
out why quick fast and in a hurry it's
so cool because Guy Gardner the Green
Lantern steps up and it's just like okay
hey look man here's the rub it seems
like you've done some pretty shady
things so before before you make a move
I want you to understand what it is
you're getting into we've crushed all
kinds of people darkside the
anti-monitor
are multiversal threat some evil
versions of Batman evil versions of
Superman we've beat the Sinestro Corps
we've beat doomsday we beat all those
all those guys
dr. Manhattan addresses John Jonah says
the reason why he's worried about me is
because he's worried about this one
vision he can get from me which is my
final view of Superman like Superman
racing towards me and trying to kill me
and so it's kind of nuts because like as
things go on like Supergirl responds
she's like so you think Superman's gonna
kill you so you want to kill him first
like firestorm freaks out because he
thinks dr. Manhattan's been screwing
with him and caused him to blow up the
guy gardener just wants to fight some
stuff so he's like okay come on let's do
this he punches dr. Manhattan knocks him
out and the Manhattan vanishes reappears
behind him and destroys his ring and
it's like the coolest thing because he's
like let me remind you of your place in
the bigger picture he's just like bad I
like like just crazy like I'm curious
this ring that you way or has power
inside of it and while I'm not there
with like the slightest bit worried
about it I am curious about it it's so
like let's just take it and it's just
like this is interesting like I know
she's kind of like I found it difficult
to affect but here's the funny thing
about this right like it's not dr.
Manhattan in try hard mode this dr.
Manhattan in like laid-back mode let's
just casually destroy some things and
then like all the magic wielders bust
out he's just kind of like this is
interesting you guys think you're
wielding magic because you're not really
wielding magic there's no real magic
here there's just you basically using
reality warping on a small scale but
only able to control what's left of the
universe you guys are able to kill you
guys are able to manipulate the
leftovers of the universe just like
you're the leftovers of the superhero
community
in some mad trash in one fell swoop he's
just like boom and just and just since
I'm all flying these guys were
ill-equipped to deal with the power of
dr. Manhattan that's exactly what this
is now kind of switching back over to to
Lex Luthor for a second so he brings
something up here he basically says like
I'm the one who gave you all the footage
of like the heroes who are supposed to
exist like the JSA that was supposed to
exist I'm the one who leaked it all to
you all the evidence that I have points
to this man the Justice League is
basically going after who's essentially
like been meddling with the timestream
and then he asked your question he says
have you ever heard of someone named
Wally West now this is big because
remember Irish West Barry Allen and hit
Wally West Kid Flash they're really the
only ones who know but is only like a
very small number of people who know
about Wally West Lex Luthor is kind of
spilling the beans to Lois Lane and
basically saying like here's everything
that's going on now this is where things
get interesting and probably where like
the old-school Watchmen fans will get a
little pissy but what happens here is
like firestorm jumps in goes to attack
dr. Manhattan says like you don't know
who you're facing off against at
Manhattan's like no you don't know who
you're facing off against and this is
when things get a little strange because
what seems to happen here is dr.
Manhattan Yanks Ronnie Raymond into the
past that's kind of a big caveat here
because as I understand it when it comes
to dr. Manhattan he moves forward in
time at the same rate as everybody else
dr. Manhattan cannot travel back and
forth through time the thing that dr.
Manhattan does as he perceives all
moments in time happening at that moment
in time right but like today's Wednesday
and it's March 6 so for dr. Manhattan
today's Wednesday and it's March 6th but
is also every day that will come after
and every day that came before but
tomorrow
dr. Manhattan will be in March 7th dr.
Manhattan cannot jump back to March 6
from 2018 he can't really like time
travel in traditional sense that seems
to be the case with his character he
doesn't really perceive it in a linear
fashion but he cannot travel back and
forth through it and so Wakanda seems to
be hinting at the idea or at the very
least outright stating dr. Manhattan can
time travel and what this is designed to
do is to kind of play mind games with
Ronnie Raymond but at the same time kind
of like retail is origin to a degree the
idea that instead of Martin Stein and
Ronnie Raymond kind of bonding together
in an accident that it was intentionally
done that that it was literally done in
a way to where Martin Stein wanted to
create a character like this and he
needed someone who would most likely
bond to him and so ultimately he chose
Ronnie Raymond because Ronnie Raymond
one reminded Martin Stein of his own son
into was a knee
a parental figure and what this does is
it reshapes everything it literally
changes the way that ronnie raymond
views himself and views martin stein and
almost kind of like sends him on a
warpath which he does I mean he
literally like freaks out and he ends up
attacking dr. Manhattan now this is when
things kind of shift back and that's
when the perspective that that's really
when geoff johns I think kind of
clarifies things that were we would look
at that initially counter we would say
okay so I guess dr. Manhattan can time
travel that's not what happened
presumably what seems to have happened
is that in the blink of an eye dr.
Manhattan basically sent them on or at
least gave ronnie raymond like a portion
of his power and essentially like rowdy
raymond saw time and the same way dr.
Manhattan does but instead of seeing
everything happening at once he
basically isolated to a single
perspective or a single point in time
so in reality they never left the
present it's just that how writing
remember saw time basically meant that
like in his mind's eye he was looking at
seven years ago to his own origin how it
was that he came into existence and the
basis behind his creation and is kind of
cool because when Ronnie Raymond attacks
like the rest of the Justice were really
the rest of the superhero community
takes it as their chance to make their
move and like the whole battle pops off
and like everyone is in this right like
all the Green Lantern's Supergirl the
entire Shazam family they all basically
channeled it into dr. Manhattan this
massive explosion goes off and dr.
Manhattan basically seems to dock the
entire superhero community presumably
kills dr. Manhattan and while that goes
on like all these different things are
happening at the same time like Wonder
Woman is making her address to the
United Nations you've got like the
superhero community that's celebrating
the fact that they killed dr. Manhattan
the message Batman wanted to send to
them to tell them they were being played
was like basically it failed to sin and
then Wonder Woman's met from nowhere and
dr. Manhattan reconstitutes himself and
literally in one fell swoop defeats the
entirety of the superhero community with
a wave of his hand they're all gone and
that was kind of solidifying the fact
that dr. Manhattan was just playing
games it wasn't dr. Manhattan fighting
to kill it was dr. Manhattan being
curious but like he's not curious
anymore
be gone and like they're all like
they're all out like that's basically it
not only that when Wonder Woman's making
her address because of the fact that all
the superheroes superheroes have left
Earth you literally have like Black Adam
and the villains who essentially like
makes their move on earth it's the
coolest thing like it's one of the
coolest things ever because right now
protecting Earth you've got Wonder Woman
Batman and Superman literally Superman's
gonna focus on document Hatton we know
that because of Manhattan's vision
Wonder Woman I guess is gonna be left to
defend the earth by yourself because
Batman's gonna race off as well it's
awesome okay so we are
continuing with Doomsday Clock God this
story's taking like two years to come
out okay the cool thing is that the big
takeaway from the last issue was
basically it was like dr. Manhattan
fighting against the Justice League it
was really more just toying with him
that was the craziest thing about the
last issue almost all the Earth's
superheroes come rolling in on Mars to
like confront dr. Manhattan and he's
just kind of swinging with him and is
like okay I'm bored now and just waves
his hand and they're all incapacitated
right it was just like this grandiose
display of how painfully outmatched they
are it gives someone with the kind of
power that dr. Manhattan has but the
great thing about this story is it picks
up with what's essentially classic
misdirection right like it picks up with
this old this old film ah there's really
just referred to as like the adjournment
right like the adjournment it's
basically like this film is being shot
with a couple of people one of which is
Harvey Coleman and for the most part
he's just kind of considered to be inept
to a degree right like he's basically an
actor that just can't pull it off as is
really what it kind of seems to be hit
out here like it's it's taken 12 takes
and he keeps forgetting what his line is
supposed to be and the funny thing about
this is that again like with dr.
Manhattan he doesn't he never released
he doesn't see time linearly the same
way we do right like we don't know what
tomorrow holds we have to wait until
tomorrow gets here to find out right
it's like that it's like that rule you
get off work at 7:00 a.m. and you go to
bed and you go to sleep people will say
well it's already tomorrow no tomorrow
starts when I wake up like that's the
way the world works and so because of
that with Manhattan seeing everything
happening all at the same time for him
like a vincit ER is supposed to happen
for us have already happened for him you
know he just sees them he just knows how
it's going to turn out and so being able
to see time simultaneously means that
again we sort of bounce around here now
of course we'll do this in a way that
that essentially makes sense but but for
Carver Coleman himself again he's kind
of considered to be like a nonsensical
actor and on top of all that he's
basically being blackmailed now of
course we end up finding out the person
is blackmailing him is his mom again
these are just kind of smaller points
here and there in reality just kind of
sets the stage for the struggle of
Carver to kind of show us the nature of
his character what it is that he's going
through he is kind of a centerpiece but
not the definitive centerpiece instead
what is up happening here is when he's
blackmailed blackmail by his mom you
know following up with that he basically
gets up gets like all the the lines
everything down perfectly so whatever
was said between the two of them the
indication is that it has a pretty
significant impact on him and so from
there we basically end up switching over
to like dr. Manhattan himself and this
is cool because what he does is he
actually sort of kind of recollect sir
it really seems to flashback among his
own memories right like
bringing Laurie the second so expect her
to Mars and of course she suffocates and
he gives her the ability to breathe and
so I'm just kind of like jumping through
these small little moments here and
there and it's kind of a cool thing
because then ultimately it basically
settles when he first arrived in the
main DC Universe on April 18th 1938 now
for those people who were familiar with
the history of DC Comics this date will
strike you in particular and the reason
why is because this is almost exactly
three months before the arrival of
Superman right like actually Comics
number one debuted in June of 1938 so
this is almost three months exactly
before a Superman pops up on the scene
and and again kind of focused being put
here on on Carver Coleman this notion
that like he's a little kid that his mom
really seems to be like a prostitute
more or less and then he gets a job
working at a at a picture studio just
working in the mailroom that eventually
like the building burns down after he
catches his boss essentially with
another man which back then was
considered to be taboo and of course
he's basically fired he ends up being
homeless and then of he's essentially
like you know ran up on by some cops who
really start beating the crap out of him
and then dr. Manhattan shows up and
that's when Manhattan begins to
basically find his anchor in in the DC
Universe and this is an important thing
because when it comes to Manhattan in in
really like The Watchmen universe he's
essentially disconnected from humanity
right he's just kind of like I'm bored
of people but with Manhattan leaving the
Watchmen universe and then coming over
to to this universe basically it's him
just kind of going through and saying
okay like I'm exploring the multiverse
now right I was the whole thing like I
just kind of broke into the multiverse
to go look at different things but it's
this idea that he's essentially starting
over right like he's it's almost like a
like a scientific experiment it's
starting over again he's somewhat
invested in it because he wants to learn
what all this is about
and that's when he starts speaking with
Carver and Carver almost addresses him
as like an angel or God and someone the
two of them sit down which is actually
kind of an interesting power that I
didn't really know Manhattan had he
actually refract light around himself to
essentially changes up here so that this
woman this waitress sees what he wants
her to see which I mean I guess for a
guy that can control the atomic
structure of matter it makes sense but
nonetheless in his discussions with
Carver what he does is really just kind
of give him like these small little bits
of information about things that'll
happen later on down the line this is
kind of a funny thing here and the
reason why is because we don't initially
find out what it is that he told him all
we know is that between the time that
Carver basically went to Hollywood to
try to become an actor and then
ultimately became a paperboy lost his
job and then got his job in the in the
adjournment that basically like
Manhattan spoke to him and talked to him
now here's
why this matters is because again
Coleman is as anchor to humanity it's
through Coleman that Manhattan begins to
sort of understand what people are like
in this universe right because there's
no assumption it's the same thing
there's no assumption that like that
when they show up here that that or at
least when he shows up here that it's
gonna be the exact same thing as the
Watchmen universe it's an impartial just
sort of looking at things and seeing how
they unfold but in the midst of all this
suddenly Manhattan is basically like he
overhears this conversation about some
guy you know basically like some guy in
Metropolis who picked up a car over his
head the introduction of Superman and he
immediately takes off because from that
point it becomes a question of okay so
basically I've traveled back to the
moment when Superman first pops up and
he actually watches the events unfold he
witnesses the events take place now this
is kind of a funny thing here because
the indication is that when this happens
when Superman picks up his car he looks
back and basically like glances at
Manhattan but he doesn't seem to see
Manhattan or if he does that he just
kind of smirks her or what have you now
a lot of that kind of goes into the idea
that I he had this smile on his face you
know is what they were saying when he
picked up the car as it was kind of a
cool thing because what Manhattan does
is literally start going through and
saying okay so Superman seems to be
where my life ends right that's the main
brunt of the story so far is that the
last thing Manhattan sees is Superman
flying at him in and you'll absolutely
pissed off and then everything goes
black and he doesn't know if it goes
black because Superman kills him or if
it goes black because he wipes
everything out and so he really just
kind of begins to sort of look at the
timeline as it was supposed to be right
and this is kind of the cool thing that
in the in in 1940 that Alan Scott was
basically you know on a like a railway
guy I mean they came across the Green
Lantern picked it up and used it and
then it basically saved him from this
train crash that was gonna happen that
that in in January of around the same
year Jay Garrick falls asleep neo and is
exposed to heavy water and ends up
becoming you know the the flash Jay
Garrick the same thing with Carter Hall
becoming Hawkman with Al Pratt becoming
the atom Kent Nelson becoming dr. fate
with Wesley Dodds becoming Sandman with
Jim Corrigan becoming becoming the
specter these origins of these
characters you know as he knows him and
as he's seen them unfold and Denis
switches over to the formation of the
JSA and this is a cool thing because
there's actually some history that Geoff
Johns pulls out here so when the JSA
meets what they do is a they kind of
start talking about like their role as
characters you know what are they going
to do as heroes and for the most part
they're not wildly familiar with each
other they're just kind of aware the
other is there now this is kind of a
cool thing because what this does is it
basically hits it like what's
essentially the first crossover between
these characters
back in the day the JSA was what's
tried-and-true the first real coming
together of a singular team like
all-star comics you know the idea of a
team sort of banding together now the
original JSA as it existed back in
all-star comics number three was
actually a team up and that's one of the
reasons why it's so cool is because
truthfully Superman number 76 is what a
lot of people point out when they say DC
first established their shared universe
but it's kind of but not really and the
reason why is because all these
characters that you see were created by
all-star publications and then the DC
side or at least the the Batman Superman
side was national allied publications it
was almost kind of like Marvel and DC so
to speak right so I mean like eventually
all-star in national allied join
together and they became Detective
Comics Incorporated but essentially this
was a sister publication now the
difference is that national allied and
all Americans shared characters right
like they were they would go back and
forth with characters but Wonder Woman
Alan Scott the original Green Lantern
Jay Garrick the original flash the
specter of these guys they were all
all-star comics and so in reality it was
kind of a shared universe strictly
within All Star Comics that's why
Superman number 76 and the formation of
a shared universe in that story the fact
that Gotham and metropolis both exists
on the same earth and that Batman as
Superman can cross over with each other
the reason why that was so big is
because that was the first time we've
seen that going into what was
essentially Detective Comics
incorporated the merging of national
allied and All Star Comics so again
that's that's why that little bit of
history there is significant but with
this team meeting up and this team
basically talking one of the things they
say is we need to find Superman and this
is kind of a cool thing because back
then when this when this was really kind
of being launched again it was for the
most part hands-off and while they did
share characters and the popularity of
Superman and Batman could have
essentially carried over to the JSA the
issue was that it wasn't and the reason
why was because they were afraid of
overexposure right because you have the
Superman comics and you had action you
had the Batman comics and you had
Detective and then not only that you
actually had Superboy that was running
around going on around the same time
both national allied and All Star were
afraid that if Superman and Batman
appeared in the JSA in addition to the
other publications they had the people
would get burned out on them but the
fact remains that like when they're
going through and they're looking at
this moment suddenly everything shifts
and it goes back to when you had Johnny
Thunder first started the picture and
saying like okay the teams all here
let's get our picture guys no one knows
who Superman is no one knows who he is
where he where he was where he's from or
anything like that essentially Superman
doesn't seem to exist and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because what he does
is dr. Manhattan travel
back to two essentially where Superman
first crash-landed in Smallville and
then of course it kind of goes through a
little bit of his origin story now we
don't really have to do this per se
because it's the origin story of
Superman right he's discovered by John
and Martha Kent they raised him
eventually they died but the thing is is
like John and Martha have died in
various ways over the years that they've
died when when like Jonathan just died
of old age
they've died when they were killed in a
car crash they died when they both died
of old age like they've both died under
different circumstances and usually it's
the result of a reboot and that's
exactly what Manhattan hits on when
Manhattan goes through all these
different stories of Superman and says
okay well John died in this circumstance
and then Martha died in that
circumstance and then John and Martha
both died in this particular
circumstance that what he's basically
doing here is he's looking at this and
saying okay if Superman goes on to
become a character that embodies hope
then let's see how far out this goes and
so what he does is he jumps all the way
to the 31st century right like when
Superboy is first brought to that era by
the Legion of super-heroes again a major
arc for Superboy back in the day when he
became like this sort of major superhero
that dealt with more than just what
Superman was doing when he was a kid and
as the Legion begins to talk to him what
we end up having is a scenario where
we're document Hatton says okay fine
then let's see what happens if I change
things so he removes the lantern from
Alan Scott's grasp and what it does is
it creates this cascading effect the
death of Alan Scott the fact that he
doesn't show up basically leads to all
these various characters not existing
Superman never is never taken to the
31st century as Superboy meaning that
point in time never really seems to
happen instead it just kind of flash
forwards a little bit and then it shows
like the new 52 origin where John and
Martha Kent are basically killed in a
car crash so again like it's one of
these things where Manhattan goes back
he looks into the future says okay the
legacy of Superman lasts well into the
31st century so let's see what happens
if we change things that what Manhattan
does is he looks down and he says this
universe as it exists this DC universe
is singular it's one of a kind the human
beings on this planet perceive the
multiverse as basically like a sort of
branch universe theory right like what
if Superman landed in Russia instead of
the United States well then you get red
Sun Superman but it's a branch off of
the existing universe that's the way it
works but what he says is that this
universe is constantly changing it's
constantly in flux it's not as though
this universe came into existence and
then it's basically maintained its exact
same form ever since it was first
created we've had crisis on Infinite
Earths we've had Infinite Crisis we've
had Final Crisis we've had zero our
crisis and
and we've had the events of Flashpoint
happen this universe has constantly
changed by one real for one reason or
another and when it did it shuffled up
the timeline things suddenly vanished
but that's the question that a lot of
people had people would sit down and
they would say okay so my question is
this if crisis on Infinite Earths
happened and it was essentially a reboot
coming out of crisis on Infinite Earths
basically there was only a singular
universe and everybody gets new origins
then what happened to things before that
they just vanished they were just gone
one day that was it
the original origin story of the JSA as
it existed in 1940 and also our comics
number three was wiped away what you got
was the version of the JSA post-crisis
that originally appear where they were
basically heroes that fought during
World War two that's the nature of
what's kind of going on here is this
idea that like all these other universes
that exist out there they do branch off
this universe but the reason why they
branch off is because the main DC
Universe is changing all the time it's
constantly in flux and that's what
Manhattan looks and that's why he did
his experiment is because he said I look
at this the history of this universe and
I see the flash Barry Allen who
initiated the flashpoint I see like the
anti-monitor I see extent I see all
these things ranging from the original
crisis to zero hour all the way running
up until you know the events of
Flashpoint and I see all these major
changes that take place so if they can
mess up the timeline then so can i I'm
just gonna use it as a grand experiment
and just see what happens it's a kid
with an ant farm is basically what this
is now the funny thing is he says like
there are a couple instances when like
the universe tried to fight back right
so like Wally West realized what was
going on and tried to break out of the
Speed Force to basically confront
Manhattan and was forced back into it
again and that goes into the events of
DC Universe rebirth number one when
Barry remembers who he is and
essentially brings him back but the cool
thing about that is that when that
happens a lot of Wally's memories were
kind of thrown into flux or wiped away
entirely
he doesn't remember any of it and that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
when he looks at this he kind of looks
at humanity and again he looks at Carver
Coleman and he says like you're going to
die we end up finding out he was
basically killed by his mom using an
award that he won but dr. Manhattan
again kind of returns back to his
disconnect it's kind of like okay so
basically is still pretty much the same
thing here like and this universe is the
same thing as the other sure they have
like super-powered beings but at the end
of the day it's all still basically the
same thing as humans running around with
these irrelevant problems that they
think are super important but they're
not because they don't really see the
grand scheme of things and their
problems are no more important than the
problems of anybody else but they think
it's the most significant thing in the
world because they believe the world
revolves around them and that's kind of
the cool thing here that's what's so
awesome about that is it basically sits
down and
says in this universe that I live in
with these experiments that I've done
with the way that I've toyed with things
way that I've screwed things up and mess
with these people's lives in this
universe of hope that literally revolves
around Superman I've essentially become
the villain and it's kind of a cool
thing he doesn't say it because he
really thinks he's a bad guy it's really
just kind of like this internal
discussion that he has I'm basically the
villain here I'm basically the bad guy
I've literally been screwing up the
timestream it's focusing on the nature
of Manhattan why has he done what he's
done because he came into this universe
he realized that like this universe is
special in the sense of every other
universe and the multiverse branches off
of it and in that the universe is
constantly changing so the question is
what happens if you change things too
fast what happens if you changed things
in the extreme what will happen with
this universe it's a science project is
basically what it is so again the
question still is still lingering does
document hatton destroy this universe or
does Superman destroy dr. Manhattan
that's the question okay so we are
getting into Doomsday Clock thank God
the newest issue a Doomsday Clock came
out honestly didn't even know if it was
gonna happen like dude this class this
story has been so delayed it's
absolutely crazy but it is really good
and it really is kind of worth it it's
pretty amazing like we finally get
answers here right which is kind of the
issue at Jeff Jones is great at writing
but sometimes he stretches things on a
bit too long especially when it takes a
story like three years to finish that
it's just like our age dude just release
it all is like a one-shot like just
release the rest of it it's like just
one trade or something like that just
like one single story anyway
so what we have going on here in this
world right now on in the DC Universe
which remember this is in continuity
this is taking place
I mean before all the stuff that's going
on right now but basically it takes
place in the main DC line of comics you
essentially have the world falling apart
right because the world has learned
about the Superman conspiracy or at
least the super may conspiracy has taken
hold in the world and then of course you
had the explosion of Ronnie Raymond in
in Moscow Russia and then you had the
superheroes taking off to Mars so to get
you guys caught up on those of you guys
who weren't really uh who aren't really
familiar with this first things first go
watch all the other videos that we've
done and the second thing is to do kind
of a rundown like a quick little
explanation here the Superman conspiracy
is this idea that floats around that
after Superman arrived in the world
right like after he basically popped up
and became Superman he left Smallville
went to Metropolis and became Superman
that what the United States started
doing was basically creating metahumans
of their own they could either be a
counter to Superman or
fight alongside Superman right it was
basically the United States government's
attempt to kind of maintain control of
the country now following that you have
the events in Moscow and the idea behind
this was that somewhere along the line
Ronnie Raymond and company ended up in
in Moscow Russia now how all that ties
together will actually find out later in
this story but basically Ronnie Raymond
ended up in in Moscow Russia
and during a major conflict he
essentially detonated and when that
happened it basically killed a multitude
of different people essentially turning
them to glass and then people saw it as
an attack by American metahumans on
Russian soil and so that basically led
to Russians attempting to retaliate
against the United States now following
this you had all the superheroes or at
least all the major superheroes from the
US who went to Mars now they were
following the trail of breadcrumbs which
led them to believe that dr. Manhattan
was on Mars albeit didn't know who he
was they just knew there was a being out
there and they had basically
hypothesized that he was the one
responsible for all of this the problem
was when they went to go face-off
against dr. Manhattan he toured with him
for about 30 seconds and then took them
all out and that was basically it right
so pretty much all the superheroes in
the United States except for Wonder
Woman Superman and Batman are basically
gone like I mean they're not dead but
they're essentially unconscious on Mars
now because of that what it does is it
picks up with the fact that the earth is
basically devolved into total chaos
right like what you're seeing right now
is essentially the way that adrian
veidt's world in the Watchmen universe
had essentially gone it's whale and I me
Adrian Veidt basically released this
giant monster into the world and with
all the death and all the destruction at
United humanity and then following that
people eventually figured out that
Adrian Veidt was the one behind it it
was all one big ruse and humanity
actually devolved to a state worse than
before and then ultimately it ended with
the Watchmen universe being engulfed in
nuclear war basically wiping out all
life on Earth at least we can just kind
of assume that was the case since you
know it was nuclear war it was it was
mutually assured destruction right it
was Matt and so because of that this
really kind of seems to be going the
same way
I like these kind of seem to be
devolving in the same process you've got
a litany of conflicts taking place right
now you've got Giganta facing off
against Wonder Woman and then suddenly
she's met by the arrival of Black Adam
now this is only end up finding out here
that in black Adams country of conduct
because of the fact that he's so
isolationist he's almost kind of taken
this magneto approach now oh really
black Adam has done this a litany of
times over the years right like I mean
you really saw it a lot in the injustice
stories but basically what what like
Adam has done here is he is isolated
conduct and said this is
a safe haven for metahumans all the
metahumans who were left on earth who
are not part of like the top tier
superheroes and they can all come to
conduct and they can basically find like
refuge now it does allow the various
metahumans to leave but the big focus
that the United States has at the moment
that is to say the American people and
even people in Russia and in some other
countries across the world is that the
United States these are the handover
Superman and the reason why is because
Vladimir Putin has issued a deadline
line he said at midnight if Superman is
not handed over to the Russian
government we launch an attack because
right now the United States has no real
superheroes but Russia does Russia has
all their various superhero forces and
so invading the United States would
actually go off pretty much without it
without a hitch and so again like
everything is kind of falling to pieces
because when all that happens you end up
having Superman of course who awakes you
know following you know his incident and
collapsing all that kind of stuff you
got Superman who basically wakes up in
two you know with this I guess a little
break having been taken with everything
kind of going to pieces with everything
going to pot and it's kind of a crazy
scenario because as that happens you end
up finding out that essentially that
Adrian Veidt is talking to somebody that
we can't really see watching these
things unfold and these makeshift
monitors and everything sort of going to
pieces you know but then of course we
end up finding out that Adrian Veidt is
actually an Arkham Asylum and the way
this whole thing plays out the releases
seems like he's an Arkham Asylum but the
way all this plays out as he walked by
one room tells us old man to be quiet
and then he basically ends up running up
on Saturn girl I remember Saturn girl
was part of the Legion of super-heroes
from the 30th century I think Ben has
changed it to the 31st century but she's
part of the Legion of super-heroes for
the future if she can read minds the
issue is that when she came back here
presumably she came back here to warn of
like a major event that was gonna happen
right that's what adrian veidt's says
like you came here to warn Superman of
something that you can possibly
understand right but the issue is that
somewhere along the line she was
basically captured and she was thrown in
Arkham Asylum at one point we don't know
exactly where she is right now but like
she was essentially captured it wasn't
able to warn Superman now because that
we end up switching over to Lex Luthor
now this is one of the most important
parts of the story right because Lex
Luthor has been working with Lois Lane
to kind of give these little bits and
pieces of information in terms of what
seems to truly be going on here and what
Lex Luthor says is that at some point
along the line that he found a
photograph now we know that this
photograph is of John rightous of dr.
Manhattan back was he back when he was
human on the watchman universe but this
this photo was brought with dr.
Manhattan over to the main DC Universe
when he arrived and the picture was
discovered the
with this is that multitudes of these
pictures have been discovered right it'd
be simple if it was just one because
what that means is that dr. Manhattan
brought the picture with him and then
when he showed up in the main DC
Universe at whatever timeframe then the
picture was basically dropped right by
accident or whatever the case may have
been he left it there and that basically
has kind of just been floating there
ever since the issue is that all these
pictures are showing up here right
they're showing up at different points
in time in the DC Universe now really
what geoff johns does it's kind of give
us a hint he won't full-on explain this
until the end but it kind of gives us a
hint right like the big moment is back
in on April 18th in 1938 now the reason
why I say this was a hit this is a hint
is because for those are guys who are
familiar with your DC history that's
when Action Comics number one was
published in the chronological timeline
of DC including all the various crises
and everything they've had that's when
Clark Kent officially like came out as
Superman right like that was his first
major act as Superman so that was a huge
moment in the history of things you go
forward and you end up finding each one
of these things has appeared at various
points in time now the question seemed
to be at least from from Lois Lane
stance does this mean that like
whoever's doing this is traveling
through time now those are the guys who
were familiar with dr. Manhattan no
that's not the case dr. Manhattan does
not time-travel right he can't jump from
the future to the past
dr. Manhattan sees all time as a
singular moment right so like he's
standing in like 2019 right he's just
kind of staring vaguely out into space
that's because he's seeing all points in
time simultaneously so it really kind of
knows where things are gonna be but he
doesn't actually go to the future he
still moves forward in time just like
everybody else does but he's not from
this universe so again like this is him
popping up here and so Lex Luthor
actually has his own theory in terms of
how it is that a man that cannot
time-travel somehow appears at different
points in time with the same picture
right because by all standards of
measurement what this looks like is it
looks like dr. Manhattan showed up on
April 13th in 1938 in the main DC
Universe when Superman first popped up
and then seemed to drop the picture or
forget about it or whatever and then
left maybe went to a different universe
or something like that then came back
but it's almost like he basically went
back to the past and then came to the
future and then went back to the past
and then came to a different point in
the future and then rinse repeat right
but we know that's not the case because
Manhattan doesn't time-travel and so
it's cool because we end up giving this
really really good explanation from
Geoff Johns towards the end of this in
terms of how all that goes down and so
really like following this you end up
picking up with reginal long now of
course again wretched along was the
son of Malcolm long and the guy who's
essentially the new Rorschach here and
while he's being held in prison he
starts experiencing these crazy visions
read these visions of his father going
in to basically speak with Walter corvax
that he's trying to plead with him hey
look don't do that don't be that guy who
does that it's only gonna destroy you
end up meeting with like Johnny Thunder
now of course that happened at some
point before Johnny Thunder basically
sacrificed his life right he died he
just kind of burned alive but then you
basically end up seeing that he's
actually speaking or at least you kind
of have this appearance of Alfred
Pennyworth now this is kind of a subtle
thing but it's also an exceedingly
important thing and the reason why is
because it's very very short and it
doesn't seem to be important but this
basically solidifies the fact that
Batman has not given up on Rorschach
remember that I was the one that grabbed
him Batman was the one that took him and
basically tossed him in the slammer and
he's kind of been there ever since but
what it means is that Batman didn't
throw him in the slammer and then just
walk away and forget about it
the Batman had a back-up plan the
back-up plan was Alfred do your homework
go through here and look at everything
about reginal long read the whole diary
of war shack the whole nine yards learn
everything you possibly can given the
circumstances right because a guy from a
different universe who doesn't really
have a life on this on this main DC
Universe but learn everything you can
and and see if what he says is true of
course cuz Batman had everything else
going on didn't really have time for it
and that's what Alfred's been doing
Alfred's been doing research he's been
poking around and he basically learned
that everything that reginal long said
is true
right like everything that he's claimed
about his life about were shaq the man
named walter corvax being worshipped
before him that all of that is true he's
not just a crazy guy but the issue is
that where you end up having Alfred
Pennyworth trying to side with him all
that you really have or at least all
that that Reggie really knows at this
point is betrayal right that's really
all he knows about his life is betrayal
losing his father
Ozymandias turning against him Batman's
doing him in the slammer that's all he
really knows so of course he ends up
bailing on Alfred Pennyworth and taking
off you know and that's when things
really sort of just kind of vanished and
because what this does is it switches
over to the answer to and to an answer
to the question that a lot of people
have been wondering about Doomsday Clock
since the beginning of Doomsday Clock
one of the questions a lot of people
have had is where Sally just Fezzik
whatever her name is like Sally Jupiter
basically and like Nite Owl to where
those characters at and we actually get
an answer here so if you recall the
characters from the previous video
marionette and mime who were basically
just criminals right they were the
street-level criminals that at some
point in their past when they were
committing a robbery that dr. Manhattan
was going to kill them but then chose
not to because of the fact that Mary
was pregnant now what Ozymandias says
here is that when this went down
everybody believed that dr. Manhattan
didn't kill marionette because of the
fact that she was pregnant but then he
started thinking literally dr. Manhattan
stood there and watch the comedian kill
a pregnant woman so like he doesn't
really care about the notion of
pregnancy like the significance of it or
anything like that it's just a human he
doesn't really care anything about who
was also housing a smaller human who
doesn't really he doesn't really care
anything about so the question was why
did he save marionette and the reason
why is because at some point along the
line marionette would give birth to
their daughter and then either they
would die or they would end up in jail
or she would have to give it up or
whatever the case says but the child
would be handed over to Sally just
Fezzik and to dan dreiberg who have
basically adopted the monikers of Hollis
now that was a that was a very end of
the Watchmen that was part of the
Watchmen story but essentially like they
adopted new identities and then went
forward as wholly new people now the
downside of this is we can largely
assume that they basically died in the
Watchmen universe right when the world
was engulfed in nuclear war that was
basically the end of it but that's what
is up happening here with with
Ozymandias is he basically starts to
break down all this bit of a story
starts to explain all these different
things and what he says here is that on
his world that it all basically engulfed
he was trying to find a way to unite it
right then he was trying to find a way
to save his world once everybody
realized that he was basically pulling a
ruse that he's the one who released the
monster that humanity didn't actually
unite itself because of some genuine
threat from a different dimension or
from outer space or however they wanted
to interpret it instead like they were
all manipulated by Ozymandias and so as
a result of this what he wanted to do
was basically save his world which was
rapidly devolved in a nuclear war which
we can largely assume by now is it's
already too late for it and at the same
time like try to find a way to save this
world which would ultimately end up
devolve into the same landscape and so
what he did is he manipulated this world
in order to save it that when he went
out and when he started poking around
and he started looking around what he
ended up discovering is that one when he
grabbed this ship and when he stowed
away and then he jumped from his
universe to this universe then as he
started going around and looking around
he discovered of course superheroes he
discovered like the flash and Wonder
Woman and Batman is Shazam and all these
characters which seemed exceedingly
impossible right I mean it is a
different universe from his own and so
if the DC if DC Comics can have a
universe or anthropomorphic animals
including captain carrot captain carrot
I love captain carrot captain cares
super bunny if you can have a universe
that basically has anthropomorphic
animals playing the role of superheroes
then you can have a you know
where you have humans who were
superheroes right like an infinite
number of universes for an infinite
number of possibilities which seemingly
only 52 have actually been discovered
according to Grant Morrison's
Multiversity and so because of that what
he did is he said okay fine there's a
way to manipulate everything there's a
way to basically get Manhattan to come
back and so what he did here is
seemingly in the blink of an eye he
engineered this plant that when he
started looking around that he learned
that the Superman conspiracy actually
had merit that while it wasn't like not
every single metahuman in the United
States is a result of government
experimentation some of them are under
Martin Stein basically the guy who would
go on to merge with Ronnie Raymond and
become firestorm that under Martin Stein
all these projects were seen they were
over seemed and they were basically
designed to create metahumans they could
either counter Superman or fight along
and monitor Superman Riley was basically
the US government never fully trusted
the Man of Steel and so they wanted to
have at least some kind of a deterrent
right as Superman was basically a really
really cool guy and then Lois Lane broke
his heart and he said you know what the
heck with humanity were like you follow
the red pill and just became this really
angry guy and then basically like tried
to wipe away the world then they would
have a way to counter that right and so
because of that but what he did is he
said okay then let's take the Superman
conspiracy and Leslie get to a guy named
named named pose are out in in Russia
rights and then Russia gets a hold of
the superman conspiracy before the US
does and then Russia starts espousing it
and so that's why you ended up having
this initial rift in the United States
because Russia was saying that the
United States is creating all these
various superheroes in response to
Superman the Superman conspiracy is real
and the American people initially
rejected it right this is just Russians
using misinformation and just doing what
they do but then detailed information
started to leak out and as that
information started to leak out humanity
began to believe it and as they started
to believe it they started to turn
against Superman following this
Ozymandias engineered the explosion of
firestorm in Russia which further seemed
to lead to the idea that if the United
States government is engineering
superheroes for the purpose of doing
whatever is they want to do and then
Russia called them on at Russia leaked
that information this is the US
government retaliating against Russia or
it's the superheroes retaliating against
Russia whatever the case is it looks
like it's the United States acting in a
defensive manner because what Russia
said was true and so it further
solidified the Superman conspiracy and
then further solidified people turning
against Superman and the various members
of the superhero community and so when
all this is basically explained we end
up having this really really cool
exchange that takes place between one
man and black Adam as well as Ozymandias
and Jupiter girl Matt Jupiter girl
Saturn draw against Mars girl uh so the
way this plays out of course is you
basically have like black Adam and his
forces will show up on the White House
lawn right which never bodes well like
any time that the Black Adam shows up it
usually means somebody's gonna get the
crap beat out of them right it's usually
way this so you end up having this kind
of exchange here right now Superman
shows up because regardless of what the
world thinks of him Superman will
continue to protect the world now that's
the nature of his character it's the way
he's always been written that's
Superman's role his his loyalty is not
to like a singular government to man's
not loyal to the US government any more
so than he would be loyal to the Russian
government or anything like that
if it's something that would endanger
people like you'll side with the
government if they need him to do
something that'll basically like stop
some some catastrophic threat right like
the US government comes to him and says
Superman there is a meteor coming to
earth and it's gonna destroy all life on
Earth we need you to work alongside the
suicide squad and stop it okay then like
he would do that but like he's not a
government stooge this is not like the
Dark Knight Returns read it does what
the government tells him to instead it's
basically one of these things where he's
an ally of Earth and having having like
like Adam show up on the White House
lawn to confront the president is
basically a scenario that goes with
Superman saying somebody has to act but
this is a problem with the Superman
conspiracy right you know in in this day
and age it's you know people choose the
facts they want right like people
believe what they want to believe and so
because of that people would look at
that and they would say well it's not
really Superman standing in like
protecting the president if Superman
protecting the government because he's a
government stooge because of the
Superman conspiracy because you know I I
believe it's true I want it to be true
so I'm going to assume it's true and and
it's interesting is it's really kind of
a social critique right at least a
critique on modern society
right like people replace factor their
opinions and then treat their opinions
as fact and so it's it's kind of
interesting you know in terms of how
this unfolds but you wouldn't having
Ozymandias who basically asked this
question to Saturn girl he says here's
the question that I have for you if you
come for the future of this timeline and
in the future of this timeline a massive
event takes place and you've come damn
warned Superman because of it here's my
question does Superman remember you
right like does he does he like in the
in whatever this future is the Superman
remember you and the response to that
question is no and so basically she
starts to vaporize because what what
awesome Annius basically says is you
come from a timeline that doesn't exist
anymore but you come from a timeline
that's not there anymore this feeds into
what dr. Manhattan had basically
discovered is that by virtue of his
actions the Legion of super-heroes
don't exist right a legion of
super-heroes ceased to exist because of
something that it is that he's done and
so as you end up having Ozymandias
passing by this this cell with this old
man we end up learning this old man is
actually Alan Scott he's the Green
Lantern which is a crazy revelation that
seemingly Alan Scott seems to be still a
lot like I don't I don't really know how
as far as I'm aware he's dead that what
end up happening is is in one of the
earlier Doomsday Clock stories that dr.
Manhattan had actually moved the lantern
away from Alan Scott so that when the
lantern landed Alan Scott didn't see it
and was hit by the train instead of in
the original comic when he saw the
Lantern crash and then he went to go
grab the lantern and because he grabbed
it he and neither he wasn't hit by the
Train right he missed the Train and so
because of that like it's it's kind of a
crazy little a little facet here because
you end up having Manhattan watching
this whole scenario unfold with Superman
fighting against like Adam and he says
like in six seconds Superman is going to
see me five four three two one
Superman meets dr. Manhattan it is here
ladies and gentlemen it is here ladies
and gentlemen yes it is just earth the
conclusion of Doomsday Clock man we've
all been vying for this only took three
years to finish okay so if you guys
remember in the in the basically
everything that's been going on over the
course of the last eleven issues for
Doomsday Clock has essentially been that
like that there were a couple things
going on and really like two major
events right it was the idea that Geoff
Johns was building this scenario well
the world was essentially coming to an
end
not really about like nuclear war or
anything like that really more about
like a metahuman war that was kind of
building up this idea that all the many
humans across the world were going to go
to war it was gonna kind of be DC's
equivalent of like the watchman's into
the world right we're in the Watchmen
universe who was basically just a
collapse you know of the world basically
by way of like nuclear warfare where
that seemed to be the case instead what
we basically had here is we had two
things happened the first was that was
the Superman conspiracy this idea that
essentially all the many humans or most
of them of the world's metahumans had
resulted from experiments in the United
States based on the work of well really
people didn't actually know where it was
from it was just like Superman had
arrived on earth and arrived in
Candice's sub portal on the line after
he showed up the federal government
sorted experimenting with creating
metahumans and that's where most of them
came from the next big thing to really
that was the whole incident that
happened in Russia with firestorm with
rotting Raymond where basically his
energy was let out in an extreme
capacity and the result was that
multiple people in in Russia were killed
I think was in Moscow itself but
multiple people in Russia were killed
and so what this members of the world
was basically on the brink of collapse
right you know what the Superman
conspiracy and all the things tied into
it the idea that the United States was
basically mass producing metahumans and
really seemed to push the world to do
closer and closer towards destruction
that that the idea of the the incident
in Russia had really kind of been the
powder keg that set it all off now the
reality was that Earth's superhero said
for the most part learned to a degree
what was going on in so far is it all
seemed to stem from Manhattan which of
course led to the battle and on Mars and
the Manhattan himself had basically
defeated pretty much all of them and
then showed up on earth to find out why
he couldn't see past Superman you know
when when he and Superman were going to
fight why he couldn't see past it and
that's where this basically picks up
this idea that like he cannot see what's
supposed to happen here he can't see
past Superman that is the crazy thing
because Superman basically does
approaches it right that's where we left
off in the last video is that Superman
was walking up to dr. Manhattan right
and it's interesting because man-hands
response here is you're the one who's
going to destroy me you're I'm the one
who's going to destroy destroy
everything I don't really know which way
it is
but essentially everything's going to
end right like everything ends and
that's kind of the cool thing here is is
because of its really Superman who
doesn't even really understand what's
going on here right like Superman is
just kind of like okay so I don't I
don't know who you are I don't know
where you're where you came from but
like you're literally telling me on the
on the cusp of this major collapse and
all these various super-powered beings
running towards me wanting to fight me
like you're telling me that like the
world's going to end or you're going to
kill me or I'm gonna kill you or
whatever the case is like I'll deal with
that here in a minute that's basically
it like I'll deal with that here in a
minute and this is kind of a funny thing
right because Manhattan is essentially
watching all of this unfold and and
under normal circumstances and given the
nature of the Watchmen universe right
when you look at characters like the
comedian when he looked at characters
like war shot you looked at uh really
like Nite Owl dan dreiberg and all these
different things normally this was just
been a fight that broke out like
Superman would have just started
attacking everybody because it's what
Manhattan is used to see and there is
everything that he's seen in the DC
Universe since he's been here but this
was really more of him just kind of
experimenting with the universe and just
sort of seeing what happens but for the
most part you kind of see a darker tone
you know
more recently where the demons gone on
and so watching this whole thing unfold
with Superman what you might end up
getting here is a guy who's basically
not like going through and trying to
kill everyone you see a guy who's trying
to fend off and trying to defend himself
against everyone making these statements
and making these claims
there's innocent people here why are you
attacking me in this place right so it's
interesting because what it does from
there is it switches over to Reggie now
remember when it came to to the
character of Reggie he basically picked
up the mantle of war Shack after Walter
Kovacs had basically died I remember
that's one of the things that was kind
of revealed here it's for Reggie he was
all built on a lie that were Mothman who
had previously died when Mothman had
looked at this and and he had basically
told Reggie that the idea was that his
father was really like getting into
getting through to corvax and like
helping corvax become a better person
the reality is that corvax was warping
the mind of Reggie's father who was the
other way around and so Marvin had
essentially lied but the reason why the
reason for this is is really kind of a
breakdown of Reggie himself because he's
approached by some guy who basically
thinks that who really seems like a
racist dick and things that Reggie's
like going to break into his place and
then of course like you basically have
Alfred Pennyworth who shows up and
basically rescues Reggie and then starts
talking to him and Reggie has kind of
been having this mental crisis because
nothing he believed to be true was
actually true instead like his father
was screwed up by Walter Kovacs he's in
wearing the mask of a man who basically
killed his father right I mean that was
the idea was not really in a literal
sense it wasn't like you know were Shaq
killed the father of Reggie but he
certainly drove him to that position you
know and so as a result of that what you
end up having here is um having ready
just kind of be like I don't want to do
this anymore I don't want to have
anything to do with this and and
ultimately Alfred really seems to try to
talk some sense into a right really kind
of seems to be like Superman needs your
help like other people out here need
your help
there's a greater purpose that can be
served here but ultimately Reggie
doesn't seem to want to listen instead
what you get is this continued neo
claimed this in Kitty and continued a
scenario with Reggie where it's like war
Shaq is a bad guy I'm wearing the mask
of a villain like of a terrible person
that kind of thing and then Batman
arrives and this is one of the coolest
things right because you would expect
Batman to play a much bigger role in
Doomsday Clock really in the latter half
of the story in the third act and what
we've seen so far but him showing up
here and him talking to Walter Kovacs is
an amazing thing because you have a lot
of other things going on in the
background right you got like mime and
Mary Ann that who are out doing their
on and so forth and there's kind of
being crazy and in doing whatever crazy
people do but Batman starts to talk
reason into Reggie and this is probably
Batman's most powerful asset the ability
to look at things objectively to remove
emotion from the equation and just say
like here's the circumstance for what it
is and one of though this is one of the
most beautiful things here what he does
his details Reggie yes your perception
of war Shaq is not what you thought it
was your perception of war Shaq was that
he was a guy who was basically trying to
save the world are doing however we're
doing whatever it was that you thought
it was that he was doing but rather that
you thought he was doing but in reality
he was the guy who basically turned your
father into the worst version of himself
right like he's the one that basically
warped and screwed up the mind of your
father and while that is the case
Mothman didn't lie to you right Byron
didn't lie to you because he wanted to
somehow trick you or deceive you or
anything like that he lied to you
because he wanted you to take the mask
of war Shaq and turn it into something
better turn it into something that means
something that can benefit the world
something that can become much greater
but here's the irony of all this is that
while Walter Kovacs himself was pretty
screwed up right he was pretty messed up
he was like Batman in the extreme right
so like that had Punisher insofar as
Walter had no problem with killing
people or anything like that like while
that was the case at the end of the day
Walter corvax was the guy who actually
stood against Adrian Veidt and was like
you can't kill that many people but you
can't be the person that does that even
if it does bring peace to the world I
can't stand idly by and let you do that
so in reality
Walter corvax actually fought on behalf
of humanity in his whole debate and
argument with with with Adrian Veidt in
the Watchmen comic which ultimately led
to his demise it was a cool moment there
but at the end of the day you know it's
one of these things where Walter was not
really as twisted and terrible as Reggie
believed he was it was just Reggie's
perception of it that's kind of the
irony of it all but in the end
Batman's response is become something
better right you see you see a monster
when you look at the mask make the mask
something to wear you look at it and you
see a hero and that's kind of the cool
thing because then what it does is it
switches back to Superman and it
switches back to dr. Manhattan and this
is awesome here because you know
literally you have like like Manhattan
just sort of talking to him remember
Manhattan's just kind of disconnected
but he's just kind of like a thing is
happening here right he's not like
overly emotional about it he's just kind
of like you know like what's gonna
happen here are you going to destroy me
I'm not gonna defend my soul like what's
going to happen if Superman comes
lunging at dr. Manhattan right
comes flying your document hat and
that's the crazy thing about this is it
doesn't really seem to be provoked right
Manhattan's just not he's not like your
mama wears combat boots does it make
it's like you so look just comes flying
out it doesn't happen that way right but
it's just Superman just starts lunging
at dr. Manhattan and the reason why he
does that is to protect Manhattan and
that is the single most important thing
because Manhattan looks at everything
that's happened basically everything
that's deaths that's taken place in the
DC Universe so far is really a result of
several different actions of dr.
Manhattan right moving the green lantern
away from Alan Scott so that he
basically is of dying you know dying in
the in the train crash as opposed to
becoming the Green Lantern and
preventing the train crash and invite
you know from that point going forward
creating the Justice Society of America
like like all these things and the
entire existence of the DC Universe as
it stands now results from like various
actions at Manhattan had committed the
flashpoint event the fact that he
stepped in the idea that he stepped in
was one who's basically saved Superman's
father from the destruction of Krypton
bringing him into the modern era
all these things that are going on are
the result of dr. Manhattan's actions
and so what he does is he kind of looks
at Superman and he expects him to attack
him because pretty much the life of
Superman as it used to be before the
events of Flashpoint versus the life of
Superman as it exists now is the result
of Manhattan meddling Mad Hatter of
Manhattan's actions or the reason why
Superman's parents are dead
different things like that and so he
would expect Japan to attack him but
instead what he ends up getting from
Superman is he basically like Superman
doesn't really just fly off the handle
that way and that's the way Superman
usually is and is the one thing about
and that Manhattan doesn't really
understand because Manhattan doesn't
really care about people anymore and so
when you don't really have an interest
in humanity and you don't really care
about why people do what they do and
you're your really major driving force
is let's just see what kind of things
can happen if I mess with them with the
multiverse and that's basically yet and
then suddenly it becomes shocking what a
person's who a person whose life you
screwed up really seems to kind of
forgive you it really wants to
understand why you did what you did as
opposed to just losing their mind and
trying to kill you and that's really
what goes on is because Superman starts
asking questions who's the woman in the
photograph you're leaving that
photograph with every step you take
everywhere you go was she important to
you and of course she was that was Janie
that was the girlfriend of dr. Manhattan
when he was younger that was the person
whose watch was left in the intrinsic
field generator he went running back in
there got locked in and then became
Manhattan right
that's the nature of his origin is it
all has to do with watches and
everything and so ultimately because of
everything that's going on here this is
where things get crazy because with
everything going on here but Superman
starts talking to him it says well maybe
maybe the darkness that you see here
maybe it takes everything that you have
to save the world right like maybe
that's maybe that's the nature of you
and so as a result about Manhattan its
identity so is okay yes I understand now
everything ends lifts his hands and it
all goes black everything ends up just
like vanishing and here's the question
to ask you right because what he says
but the way this narrative goes from
Manhattan he says it all begins with a
child right it begins with Superman
all right the Metaverse forms around
this one and only person everything that
takes place the entire all everything
that happens in the DC Universe all
revolves around Superman Superman comes
flying in he crash-lands on earth and
then in turn what is up happening is
Manhattan goes back and basically starts
to undo the various things that he did
that when Alan Scott died during the
train crash as a result of Manhattan
moving the lantern Manhattan moves the
lantern back and so Alan Scott discovers
the lantern becomes a Green Lantern
saves the day and so where previously
the origin of Superman was there were no
superheroes before him and his father
literally tells him the world's not
ready for a person like you because
they've never seen a person like you
before with the lantern being moved back
with Alan Scott basically becoming the
Green Lantern like he was supposed to be
then suddenly the origin of Johnna or
the the scenario Jonathan Kent shifts
and it says the world has seen people
like this before so if you really
believe that you that your powers give
you something to offer the world and if
you really believe that you can become
something special in something great
then just get out there and do your
thing son and the result of this is that
where Hart could not really stepped into
the role of embracing his powers uh you
know during the universe or during the
time when Alan Scott never became the
Green Lantern his parents died in a car
wreck but in this instance because of
the fact that he did embrace his powers
because he his father gave him words of
encouragement instead of words of
discouragement when the time came where
they were supposed to die in a car crash
Clark Kents there and he saves him he
saves the lives of John John and Martha
Kent so it's that cascading effect right
the actions of Manhattan when he came in
and removed the lantern and Alan Scott
died resulted in Alan Scott never
becoming the Green Lantern meaning
Superman was never inspired to become
Superman meaning his parents died in a
car wreck because his father had
discouraged him instead of encouraging
him and of course things transpired
accordingly but with Alan Scott becoming
the Green Lantern now what does
is that a singular action can have this
massive cascading effect along this
great big huge timeline over and over
and over again and that's a crazy thing
about is because Superman
now basically becomes Superboy who in
turns steps in and the Legion of
super-heroes of course travels back in
time recruits super what all these
things basically begin to unfold with
regards to Superman's impact on the
greater landscape Johnny Thunder who had
long since been searching for his genie
but actually forgotten about it is
basically inspired to return to it and
so Johnny Thunder goes back to being
Johnny Thunder the way he was before
Saturn girl jumps back to the 31st
century everything starts snapping back
in place the way it was supposed to
basically what this looks like is going
on and this is where things get this is
where things get kind of crazy what it
looks like it's going on here I'm not
gonna claim this but what it looks like
Geoff Johns is doing is resetting the
entire timeline right busy it's not even
really a crisis it kind of feels like a
soft reboot and the reason why I say
that is because in the midst of this
conflict where Superman is getting
pummeled by all these various
super-powered people right Black Adam
and all these various individuals you
know they're like literally out of
nowhere it's like you remember us now
don't you right because now they're a
part of the timeline but Superman didn't
remember them before because they never
existed before right the the the Legion
of super-heroes never came back from the
31st century because Superman was never
Superboy so there was no reason for the
Legion of super-heroes to come back and
seemingly they didn't didn't really seem
to exist because they weren't inspired
by Superboy who was brought to the 31st
century at some point in time like
literally because ala Scott's there
because the Justice Society was created
because super super warrior I guess
Clark was inspired to become Superboy
and embrace his powers because of this
very big huge change in the cascading
effect really in the timeline itself
suddenly all these heroes start popping
up and one of them one of them says
sorry we're late son and ultimately sir
man says well it's better late than
never and what we get is the return of
the Justice like the Justice Society of
America and the Legion of super-heroes
like all these characters are back like
they're back now in DC Comics and that's
crazy it's amazing to see like like
basically what we're getting is pretty
much what it looks like the DC landscape
before like like at least in terms of
Heroes before the events of the new 52
all the characters are back now the
Justice Society of America is back the
Legion of super-heroes is back and
everybody remembers who the other person
is and it's awesome to see released
Superman does and the question is like
will
people like the flash remember who they
are but essentially Superman has this
colossal group of teammates fighting on
his behalf not only that what dr.
Manhattan does is witness and really
begin to understand that everything
really does revolve around Superman that
all these different universes exist out
there and in every single universe
Superman always comes into existence
right so you know during the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths the entire
multiverse was reset basically down to a
singular universe there was just
Superman everything always revolves
around Superman now here's one of the
craziest things to consider here the
line of DC Comics that we saw between DC
showcase issue number four when Barry
Allen first showed up as a flash leading
up to the destruction of the multiverse
in in crisis on Infinite Earths that's
not that's no longer referred to as
earth one as it was back then instead
now is called Earth 1985 and like it's a
universe out there right like it's a
universe that exists out there and has
never been explored why Divac says that
you know a world unexplored even today
right he goes with FAR's and this this
is where things get crazy as goes as far
as the same that there's a universe out
there that exists right like earth 52 is
out there soon as soon essentially like
the new 52 universe exists out there as
a separate universe Jeff Jones is going
through and one either picking and
choosing the various universes from
convergence and kind of keeping them
there building on what we already know
in terms of like what universes are
there but basically saying that like
there's all these alternate realities
out there now I would not be surprised
if in the aftermath of this we got
something akin to like zero hour crisis
in time but for the multiverse right
like after zero hour back in the 90s
they kind of gave us like the Marvel
gave us this big I'm sorry do you see
give us this big timeline of like when
things happen in the universe right like
when Superman arrived on earth when
Batman was born different things like
that it didn't last somebody really
stuck to it but I wouldn't be surprised
if we got basically like a new
multiversal map basically like how this
map works what these worlds are
different things along those lines is a
cool thing to see not only that Geoff
Johns
looks like he's teasing future crises
like future events right like he says
like this is it in the year 2020
Superman's timeline is bombarded by the
reckless energies of the old gods once
again warping the multi or the Metaverse
now I don't know I assume he's referring
to Darkseid war when he says this like I
assume that's what he's referencing
there I could be wrong like my thought
is if we're talking about the year 2020
the nest next year we're talking about
like what's going on in Justice League
right now like with Perpetua the the
anti-monitor the monitor
the forger of worlds and so on and so
forth but then you get July 2nd 2025 a
crisis unlike any other the Metaverse
has ever seen will erupted calling it
the time masters I thought he was
representing the old time masters comic
from 1990 I don't think he is like I
think you seem like there's going to be
a crisis like a major crisis in 5 years
which is kind of a long time like we're
6 years rather it's kind of a long time
to do into another crisis but like in
its wake Superman is revitalized it's
this constant thing right these constant
set of events and it goes on and on and
on and on what he basically says is that
no matter what the alternate reality is
no matter what universe it's in no
matter what time period Superman arrives
in that universe that universe revolves
around Superman that there might be
superheroes before him but Superman uh
sure 'he's in a whole new era that had
never been seen before his arrival right
before he stepped onto the scene he's
the most significant and the most
important hero and so as a result of
that what is up happening is Manhattan
basically starts snatching people away
right he snatches away Adrian Veidt he
snatches away mime and marionette he
snatches away the comedian he takes away
like like Reggie like brings them all to
his location and it's kind of a crazy
thing there because what you end up
having is basically him talking with
Adrian Veidt and adrian veidt's response
is you didn't care enough to save our
world right there was no way to get you
back to save our world you thought our
world was beyond hope and you felt like
civilization on our world was beyond
hope what you needed was to be inspired
you needed somebody who could strike you
in such a way to where it would totally
shift your perception that's what had to
happen here as Manhattan had to kind of
be yanked away from his disconnect from
humanity and reconnect his humanity
again and in adrian veidt's mine the
only way to do that was to take him to a
place where super-powered beings despite
all the various powers that they had
were still human right they still were
still capable of fantastic things and
they in and of themselves were inspiring
and so if he wanted to inspire Manhattan
then take him to a world of people who
could inspire him most notably Superman
and so with Manhattan's seeing
everything that goes on Noah Manhattan
with Jewish staying knowing Manhattan
would mess with things he'd be curious
and so on and so forth
the idea was to engineer set of
circumstances where ultimately Manhattan
would end up in this particular universe
and become inspired by Superman and then
be inspired to save the world and then
by doing that by getting Manhattan to
reconnect with himself the idea was then
to somehow bring Manhattan back to the
Watchmen universe and get Manhattan to
fix the Watchmen universe he was all the
grand scheme of Adrian Veidt to save his
own world
of course at that point comedian like
shoots him in the stomach or shoots him
in the chest and he's just like you're
out of luck man like your times done
like that's it and then Lex Luthor comes
out of nowhere basically just like ends
up ends up screwing up the the temporal
energies of comedian and basically sends
him back to where he came from right so
it's Geoff Johns away ously okay
comedian your time it's done here back
to the watching universe where you got
thrown out of the building by Adrian
Veidt and and then now you're going back
to being dead again right and so
basically he kind of gets it right back
to the moment in which he died where he
was snatched away by Manhattan and
brought into the DC Universe but it's
sort of nuts because like from there you
you literally have these these scenarios
where you really had Manhattan talking
with my my marionette I really sort of
explained in this whole situation
too that when the question was like you
gotta even when they say you have to
send us back to our universe because we
need our son rather he starts telling
them about how like no you have a
daughter that's basically on the way
right now ask for your son my plan is
that you'll see each other again
you know he'll de he'll need an anchor
here in this universe so basically mime
and marionette are being left behind in
the DC Universe they're staying here and
are not going back to the hwachun
universe now this is important right
because we've seen geoff johns do this
before it specifically with blackest
night in brightest day that was the
whole idea behind those two stories
blackest night was was basically
designed to bring back every single
superhero and every single super villain
who ever died right to bring them all
back and then brightest day was designed
to keep particular individuals right not
all of them but to keep particular
individuals and then in turn allow them
to stay as part of the DC landscape
everybody else just wasn't popular
enough to keep around so they all end up
going back to being dead again and so as
a result of that it's kind of a cool
thing because what he does is kind of
begin that the process is sort of
reconnecting looking looking at the
world as it exists now with the return
of the Justice Society of America having
been inspired by Superman and it's like
a whole new day right because then from
that point he jumps back to the Watchmen
reality right ended up jumping back to
the watchman dimension and when he does
he basically begins the process of
restoring things back after that like
it's going from location to location
right to sort of why you know we we get
this kind of explanation of the world as
it unfolds right the world as it exists
now Reggie you know Rorschach looks like
he's staying in the DC Universe and by
remaining in this DC universe he's now a
character that can be used at some point
along the line how that will fare I have
no idea but I imagine him probably
getting a solo book you know but in turn
what also ends up happening is that with
the child is being warned by mine and
marionette of course man hadn't really
kind of makes reference to this idea
that he's not really able to
understand it doesn't really seem to be
able to grasp the details of what's
going on with the son of mime and
marionette only for us to find out the
reason why he can do that is because the
the blind spot with a child is because
of him right the blind spot with a
child's future the fact that he can't
see that child's future is a result of
Manhattan himself and the reason for
this is because Manhattan took the son
of Miami marionette right he took this
child away and then in turn went forward
into the world took the child to Mars
you know kind of looked at how these
things unfolded and basically grabbed
the child and said okay this kid now is
going to essentially receive all of my
powers and that's exactly what he does
and he basically kind of disperses
himself out there and then puts his
powers within this child right so
Manhattan as he traditionally exists is
no longer in existence now right so it's
like what you guys saw at the end of the
Washington TV show which I surmise is
the reason why it took so long for this
comic to come out so it could kind of
but the ending could coincide with the
show and people could basically identify
with the two concepts and understand
what's going on but with this child's
basically receiving the powers of dr.
Manhattan what this does is it basically
transitions to the home of dan dreiberg
and in Laurie right I mean we you guys
know where they are rightly you guys
know what's you know Silk Spectre and
and in and night out of course they're
much older now you know the world
Honeyman that the Watchmen world having
basically been saved by dr. Manhattan
the other daughter basically shows up
and it's just kind of like okay cool
right because this is the daughter of
mama marionette there's basically being
raised by dan dreiberg and laurie
juspeczyk and so because that like the
kid shows up on the front door and it's
just like you know she says hey my
name's Sally you know what's yours and
you know he's like what my name is Clark
John brought me here and said that like
your parents would know what to do it's
a beautiful ending because basically you
have kind of a dr. Manhattan reborn with
all these various powers but with no
real ties or agonal aside from the
powers no real ties to the history of
the original dr. Manhattan but with like
an insane amount of abilities it's
interesting and it's actually really
really cool I'm pretty excited about it
what this does is it leaves these
characters kind of open right Adrian
Veidt didn't die Adrian Veidt was
basically put in a prison meaning Adrian
Veidt is now in the DC Universe
Rorschach is now in the DC Universe all
these characters aside from the comedian
are now in the DC universe the only
exception here is the son of mono
marionette calling himself Clark and
possessing the powers of dr. Manhattan
now something else to point out of here
and this is entirely possible it could
be the Manhattan brought these folks
here from the watchbird universe right
but again it seems as though this is all
taking place in the Watchmen universe
you know with regards to the daughter of
mama marionette Sally
that's basically being raised by laurie
juspeczyk and dan dreiberg it's cool
like it's really really amazing I think
it's a fitting end of the story was I
expecting like this great big huge
knock-down drag-out fight between
Superman and dr. Manhattan yeah but like
what chance was Superman really have
though against that kind of power so it
kind of makes sense we wouldn't really
see it and I think it speaks more to the
nature of Superman that he was inspiring
for Manhattan than anything else but
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explain make sure you guys to
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys want to see my
uncensored vs. videos were all we're
doing a whole bunch of like vs. dr.
Manhattan vs. videos right now if you
guys are interested in seeing that
heavily patreon.com slash comments
explained and if you enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace we've got some
new patrons in our top tears over on
patreon.com slash comments explained I
want to give a shout out to Jason see
Austin s Jason s Austin H Phillip and
Austin B as well as Steven Z Eagle F
Joey M and Jeff are as well as Genesis
916 as always we just usually keep the
last name - an initial it helps you guys
to maintain your anonymity some of you
guys are expressed concerned about
having like your first and last name
thrown out there for the world to see I
do not blame you for you guys who have
joined up as part of our patreon tiers
that are eligible for Rob port honor
guard rings those whose rings have been
sent out you should already have them if
you're a new person who just joined up
and you've been part of this - here for
a month your ring will be mailed out to
you so I want to say thank you guys for
beating patrons
[Music]